voilà donc je propose de commencer notre
audition et cette table ronde qui porte
sur le rôle des collectivités
territoriales en matière de rénovation
énergétique je vous remercie les uns et
les autres de votre présence pour que
nous puissions conduire cette audition
et avoir les échanges qui soient les
plus intéressants possibles et surtout
porteurs de d'avancer en tout cas nous
le souhaitons donc nous recevons
aujourd'hui les représentants de
plusieurs associations d'élus
l'Association des maires de France qui
représentaient ce matin par Monsieur Guy
Geoffroy qui est son vice-président et
qui est maire de Combs-la-Ville et qui
est président des maires de
Seine-et-Marne
nationale de rénovation énergétique
notamment en offrant de nombreuses aides
locales à commencer par des dispositifs
d'informations et d'accompagnement qui
permettent le déploiement local et
l'adaptation mais parfois aussi devant
ce qui est décidé à Paris ces actions en
matière de rénovation sincère d'ailleurs
dans une politique et des compétences
plus larges en matière d'urbanisme et de
logement les citoyens ne s'y trompent
pas et se tournent en première intention
vers leurs élus locaux et les services
des collectivités pour être guidés et
pour être sécurisé dans leur démarche
nos collectivités conservent des
services de proximité et de contact avec
les populations ce que ne font pas ou ne
font plus les grandes agences nationales
ou les services de l'État
dès lors je voudrais vous interroger sur
la manière dont vous voyez le devenir de
France rénov et de l'accompagneur
l'accompagnateur Renov au regard de ce
qui existe déjà de leur financement et
de leur déploiement sur tout le
territoire
Antoine payillon le secrétaire général à
la planification écologique que nous
avons auditionné la semaine dernière à
annoncé à notre commission d'enquête le
déploiement d'un guichet d'accueil et
d'orientation dans chaque EPCI d'ici à
2025 qu'en pensez-vous
faut-il aller plus loin dans
l'accompagnement et l'unicité des
démarches il me semble que les
dynamiques locales sont déjà
particulièrement importantes pour jouer
un rôle d'entraînement à travers des
rénovations réussies au risque cependant
d'accroître les inégalités entre les
collectivités ayant les plus de moyens
et les autres comme nous l'avons vu en
Isère dans le cadre actuel nous avons
reçu plusieurs témoignages de
collectivités qui déplorent n'avoir
aucune prise sur les aides relevant de
ma prime rénov n'ayant aucune
information ou facilité à en obtenir
pour accompagner des citoyens parfois en
attente ou dans l'incompréhension alors
même que ces collectivités peuvent être
délégataires d'autres aides Anna au
titre par exemple des aides de la pierre
comment pourrait-on améliorer cette
situation
en matière immobilière je souhaiterais
connaître la manière dont vous percevez
sur vos territoires les conséquences du
calendrier de la loi climat et
résilience dans vos territoires sur le
marché locatif mais aussi sur les
logements qui sont les plus énergivores
observez-vous une tension accrue sur le
marché locatif et une augmentation des
mises en vente enfin la rénovation est
également une question de structuration
d'une filière économique des matériaux
aux hommes et femmes qui réalisent les
travaux comment vos collectivités
s'engagent-elles pour accompagner ce
secteur d'activité afin de réussir la
transition écologique voilà déjà un
certain nombre de questions auxquelles
vous allez pouvoir répondre donc pour un
propos introductif que vous vous
partagerez comme vous le souhaitez les
uns et les autres il me revient
maintenant de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat
est un compte rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de 3 ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et de
45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende je
vous invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
a levé la main droite et à dire je le
jure donc je vous propose peut-être de
commencer par Monsieur Geoffroy puisant
à la suite des autres si vous le voulez
bien ce vous prêter à ce formalisme
et bien je vous en remercie et donc je
vous cède la parole avant que notre
rapporteur vous pose un syndrome de
questions ainsi que nos collègues qui
sont membres de la commission d'enquête
et qui sont présents à cette audition
alors je sais pas on commence par vous
monsieur Geoffroy peut-être et puis on
va suivre le l'ordre qui a été établi
sur cette travée merci à vous très bien
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et Messieurs les sénateur et
c'est la triste qui nous accueillait
aujourd'hui
comme vous l'avez dit dans votre peau
pointeductif le sujet est très vaste
d'une très grande diversité d'approche à
la fois globale philosophique même je
dirais jusqu'à des aspects extrêmement
concrets de proximité aussi comme vous
l'avez d'ailleurs évoqué dans votre
courrier d'invitation notre Association
des Maires de France vous fera parvenir
un tout document
allant dans la meilleure des précisions
possible et maintenant de l'ensemble des
commissions du groupe de travail qui
réfléchissent sur l'ensemble de ces
sujets ce qui explique que mon propos
introductif et les questions
qu'éventuellement j'apporterai les
réponses que j'apporterai à vos
questions c'est forceront d'être aussi
précises que possible mais ne pourront
pas aller jusqu'à l'exhaustivité du
propos et je pense que tout le monde en
conviendra dans ce propos introductif je
souhaiterais à alerter sur
à la fois ce que sont les dispositions
ce qu'elle risque d'entraîner et
ce qui serait éventuellement envisagé et
par rapport à quoi nous aimerions
aujourd'hui formuler un certain nombre
d'observation et pourquoi pas de
proposition
la première remarque Par rapport donc
aux dispositions de l'article 160 de la
loi climat et résilience dont on sait
qu'elles sont pour l'essentiel
issu des réflexions de la convention
citoyenne c'est que elles ont conduit à
ce que le Parlement décide de limiter
les dispositions qu'on peut qualifier de
contraignantes à un calendrier on y
viendra puisque vous l'avez évoqué et à
un simple mais parfois complexe face à
face entre le propriétaire privé et son
locataire la première remarque que nous
faisons c'est que une des propositions
séries de proposition de la convention
citoyenne consistant à ce qu'il y ait en
parallèle avec la judiciarisation entre
deux personnes un propriétaire et un
locataire qu'il y ait des mesures de
nature plus
administratives et donc à la disposition
des autorités administratives ils sont
les représentants de l'État pour ce qui
est concerne mais également les élus
locaux dans le cadre de leur pouvoir
réglementaire local n'est pas été retenu
et en particulier des dispositions comme
celles qui avaient été évoquées qu'on
peut appeler un malus taxe foncière qui
aurait le permis aux collectivités et en
particulier aux communes dont on sait
que la taxe foncière sur les propriétés
bâti et non bâtirest la seule recette
fiscale sur laquelle ils ont une
possibilité d'agir qui aurait donné à
ses collectivités la possibilité de
disposer de ressources complémentaires
au cas où elle serait appelée à
contribuer d'une manière ou d'une autre
à atteindre les objectifs fixés par la
loi donc nous sommes persuadés que tout
dépasse sanctions mais que si il y a une
par sanction elle doit déborder le cadre
toujours complexe à mettre en œuvre de
poursuite judiciaire de la part dans le
locataire vers un propriétaire quand on
sait que la complexité des méandres tout
à fait nécessaire par ailleurs des
procédures devant les tribunaux
judiciaires peut d'emblée conduire
certains locataires à abandonner tout
simplement l'idée ou même à ne pas avoir
l'idée
d'exiger du propriétaire parfois de
justice
qu'ils permettent au logement d'être
décent ou de le devenir dans le cadre de
la mise en oeuvre justement des
dispositions de la loi ce qui me permet
de formuler une remarque d'ordre général
que nous avons déjà formulé sur sur
d'autres sujets et en particulier sur le
sujet zan qui n'est pas totalement
éloigné à un de nos préoccupations
d'aujourd'hui c'est que oui il faut
fixer un calendrier il faut fixer des
objectifs et que ne pas fixer de dates
butoir pour atteindre ses objectifs et
toujours un problème comme devient un
problème le fait d'établir un calendrier
dont le caractère certes progressif mais
pour les premières dispositions toujours
rapprochées à
démontre d'emblée la difficulté de
l'atteindre et donc fragilise la
crédibilité du dispositif c'est sûr que
la progressivité je l'ai sous les yeux
du passage à de l'exclusion progressive
des classes en remontant le tableau vers
le a
est intellectuellement compréhensible
mais nous sommes persuadés à un nous
acteur de terrain au contact très
concret des réalités de chaque jour que
le respect de ce calendrier sera
extrêmement difficile à atteindre ça
c'est la première série de remarques que
je souhaitais faire au nom de la
deuxième série de remarques c'est sur
les
les conséquences
potentielles par stratégie de
détournement des objectifs et surtout du
calendrier de mise en oeuvre de la loi
qui pourrait être utilisé par certains
propriétaires avec tous les problèmes
que ça pose on sait très bien que les
dispositions de la loi s'appliquent
au logement loué à une personne privée
ça ne s'applique pas aux meublé donc le
risque de transformation de logements
insusceptible par la volonté ou par
autre chose que la volonté du
propriétaire de rentrer dans le cadre
légal
sortir de ce cadre légal en devenant
logement meublé bon est un véritable
souci bon et puis il est bien clair que
il peut y avoir également la
dénomination de résidence secondaire
même si elle n'est pas occupée même si
ça peut ent bien sûr en tant que
résidence secondaire le paiement au
profit de la commune de la taxe
d'habitation éventuellement majorée du
fait que le logement n'est pas occupé
mais sur la question de la disponibilité
du parc locatif au sein de nos communes
c'est un vrai sujet d'autant plus si
vous l'avez souligné madame la
Présidente que nous savons très bien que
la règle si je peux l'appeler ainsi
c'est l'extrême diversité des situations
sur tout le territoire national et pas
simplement entre commune dit urbaine
d'un côté commune dites rural de l'autre
mais au sein de l'ensemble de cette
diversité il n'y a pas une seule
communion urbaine qui ressemble à aucune
autre en matière de d'état des lieux de
logements
indécent non décent et du fait de son
caractère de passoire énergétique et
même en milieu rural c'est le cas
également et quand on sait surtout en
zone tendue ça ce qui concerne plus bien
sûr le secteur urbain combien est grand
la difficulté de développer le logement
neuf surtout dans le parc social pour
atteindre d'autres objectifs qui sont
ceux par ailleurs tout à fait
compréhensible de la loi et ces rues de
la loi allure on voit la difficulté
perverses par certaines pratiques des
dispositions actuellement mises en place
par la loi dans la disponibilité de
logements donc dans le règlement d'une
question qui reste un problème majeur
dans notre pays qui est le logement
descend pour tout le monde
difficile à atteindre déjà et qui
pourrait malencontreusement être aggravé
du fait des dispositions dont la
difficulté de mise en oeuvre serait tout
à fait évidente le troisième sujet et
j'en terminerai là pour ne pas être trop
long dans ce propos liminaire sur lequel
nous souhaitons attirer l'attention de
votre commission d'enquête c'est sur les
perspectives qui ont été ouvertes dans
les échanges avec le chef de l'État et
le gouvernement sur la question
perspective de décentralisation de
compétences sur des sujets de cette
nature dont
l'idée même et le principe même n'est
pas ne sont pas un seul lents dans la
mesure où vous l'avez dit et nous le
revendiquons aussi souvent c'est la
proximité qui fait la bonne connaissance
des choses et qui fait la bonne capacité
à
prendre toute disposition permettant
d'améliorer l'état de la question
si il doit y avoir et pourquoi pas le
jour venu à une décentralisation des
politiques de lutte contre
les logements énergivores et donc contre
le logement non décent d'une manière
plus globale
il faut au préalable que les choses
soient très claires
qu'elles soient claires d'abord sur
l'état des lieux tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui fait ou plutôt non fait il
est impératif que l'État c'est sa
responsabilité à faire en sorte et
l'ensemble des collectivités j'en suis
persuadé seront de ce partenariat face
en sorte que l'on connaisse bien l'état
des choses avant d'envisager quoi que ce
soit et la deuxième remarque elle est de
fond et elle est
considérable dans la préoccupation qu'on
les élus locaux c'est que on ne peut pas
envisager de décentraliser quoi que ce
soit sans que ce soit traité enfin
sérieusement la question du transfert
des moyens permettant d'exercer la
compétence transférée
nous connaissons trop ce que fait l'état
de certains outils liés à la
décentralisation j'en prends au hasard
la DGF qui n'est pas un cadeau fait par
l'État aux collectivités mais qui est un
du
par au collectivités par l'État on a vu
la ponction considérable effectuée à un
tiers en gros ce qui n'est quand même
pas négligeable par l'État sur la DGF un
détriment des politiques publiques pour
lesquelles la DGF avait été créée
il est clair que la tendance est plutôt
celle là et que même s'il faut trouver
le moyen de mettre fin au gouffre de la
dette publique ce n'est certainement pas
du côté des collectivités locales qu'il
faut essayer de trouver des ressources
supplémentaires
c'est la seule fois que je prendrai
l'exemple d'une commune que je connais
bien celle que j'administre depuis 28
ans
ma modeste commune de 22000 habitants à
tout bonnement en franc courant je parle
pas de franc constant en euros au
courant et non pas de reconstant a perdu
depuis 2014 la modique somme de 12
millions d'euros à 12 millions d'euros
que nous aurions reçu de l'État a
supposer que l'État ne décida pas
d'augmenter d'un seul centime cette
contribution de 2014 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
rien qu'en maintenant cette somme nous
aurions aujourd'hui 12 millions d'euros
de plus comparé au montant de la dette
de la commune qui s'élève à 15 millions
vous voyez un peu quelle est la
différence donc il est absolument
inenvisageable inenvisageable que la
question de la décentralisation de ces
politiques publiques essentielles à
atteindre dans les objectifs auxquels
nous adhérons puissent se faire dans un
cadre qui soit vous voulez plus de
décentralisation pour avoir plus de
pouvoir d'agir on vous le donne sans
qu'on nous donne les moyens de le faire
j'ai évoqué au début mon propos la
question des ressources complémentaires
qu'aurait permis par exemple à la
sanction taxe foncière que nous aurions
pu utiliser pour récupérer des sommes
utiles à la lutte globale contre les
passoires thermiques vraiment sur cette
question de l'éventualité de
décentraliser donc de donner au pouvoir
public locaux la capacité de mieux agir
parce qu'ils sont les mieux placés pour
le faire ne peut pas passer par une
visite sérieuse loyale entre l'État et
les collectivités locales à un des
conditions dans lesquelles toute action
de décentralisation peut se mettre en
place de manière intelligible et
responsable
merci beaucoup monsieur le
vice-président pour ces propos
introductifs laisse la parole à Monsieur
Masson vice-président et au nom de
France urbaine oui alors je vais essayer
d'être complémentaire par rapport à
l'intervention qui vient d'être faite
puisqu'il y a un certain nombre de
points qui nous rassemble bien sûr
vous dire d'abord que puisque vous
tentez de vous projeter sur les mesures
à prendre qui seraient j'allais dire
intelligente pour tout le monde et qui
nous permettrait d'avancer un peu plus
vite quand même reprendre deux ou trois
points qui nous posent problème
aujourd'hui
tout d'abord pour prendre la chose de
manière la plus proche du citoyen c'est
le fait que la complexité vous l'avez
soulignée dans votre propos d'ailleurs
et particulièrement grande et du coup
elle est grande pour le citoyen elle est
grande aussi pour les collectivités
c'est à dire que quand on doit mettre en
place un certain nombre de dispositifs
on a on est face à des modifications
constantes de ces dispositifs des
complémentarités des adjonctions des
soustractions d'un certain nombre de
d'éléments qui font que l'exercice n'est
pas facile d'autant que par ailleurs
finalement il y a il faut bien voir
qu'il y a deux façons de parler aux
citoyens aujourd'hui de ce sujet il y a
effectivement l'action j'allais dire des
pouvoirs publics au sens large
collectivité état mais il y a aussi
celui des entreprises et du coup on a
deux canaux qui sont parallèles et qui
aboutissent à ce que il y ait finalement
une méfiance de plus en plus grande de
la part de celui qui souhaite rénover
son habitat et ça c'est un élément qui
est un élément de à la fois de
complexité et évidemment de non-action à
l'arrivée donc il y a une première
question et finalement une proposition
qu'on peut faire c'est d'avoir un
système un ique qui oblige par exemple à
dans tous les cas à passer par les
dispositif public avant de se lancer sur
des rénovations
s'ajoute à cela dans le constat le fait
qu'on a eu des campagnes à 1 euro je
rentrerai pas dans le détail tout le
monde en a entendu parler des campagnes
sur la pompe à chaleur et le fait que
et ça aussi ça contribue à la perte de
confiance
le fait que les résultats ne sont pas au
rendez-vous ça c'est absolument
fondamental puisque nous en tant que
collectivité nous avons le contact avec
un certain nombre de gens qui viennent
nous voir un peu désespérés en disant
bah là isolation 1 euro bah désolé mais
j'ai pas vu les choses s'améliorer alors
il est vrai que il faut peut-être le
démoliser
au niveau parce que les gens regardent
finalement ce qu'il paye et comme on a
constaté une augmentation non
négligeable des coûts évidemment ça pèse
mais quand on regarde un peu dans le
détail ce que nous présente les gens
c'est aussi des augmentations de des non
baisse de consommation par rapport à ce
qui est promis même chose pour la pompe
à chaleur on sait tous que le fait de
changer
les moyens de chauffage en premier et la
plus mauvaise opération pour l'avenir
j'allais dire du bâtiment dans sa
globalité en termes de rénovation donc
on a des politiques publiques qui
aujourd'hui sont assez contradictoires
avec les objectifs qu'on doit atteindre
et du coup qui sont chers et peu
efficaces
donc ça a été dit et sur ce terrain nous
souhaiterions avoir l'équivalent des
aides à la pierre c'est à dire des aides
à la rénovation énergétique qui serait
un moyen évidemment de d'aller vers le
guichet unique alors j'ai entendu que
vous nous avez annoncé que Monsieur
Peillon
envisageait un guichet d'accueil et
d'orientation dans les EPCI
c'est à l'analyse qu'il faudra regarder
mais il faut avoir une certaine prudence
pourvu qu'on n'est pas un élément
supplémentaire difficile à gérer et je
rappelle quand même que nous avons des
dispositifs déjà financés par les
collectivités sur ce sujet notamment les
Alecs donc voilà je veux dire il faut
multiplier les guichets uniques semblent
assez incontresens pour atteindre
l'objectif
autre élément sur lequel je souhaitais
insister sur ce champ c'est la
neutralité de la formation c'est à dire
que puisque j'ai mis en avant les
difficultés du citoyen à faire confiance
au système il est fait pas confiance non
plus parce que il a pas le sentiment que
la neutralité respectée en tous les cas
pardon tous les cas de figure alors là
il y a beaucoup de d'informations sur
tout ce que sont les arnaques etc et le
fait que les choix soient très orientés
donc
cet ensemble aboutit quand même à ce
qu'il y ait une vraie difficulté qui se
double pour nous sur les territoires des
problèmes de précarité énergétique c'est
à dire que on est là pour le coup en
première ligne sur ce sujet et c'est
vrai qu'être relativement démuni alors
je sais il y en a enfin voilà vous
connaissez tout ça mais le fait d'être
relativement démuni pour aller vite
vis-à-vis de ces populations est un
problème
l'augmentation du nombre de précaires
énergétiques liés à l'augmentation des
prix et importante
et ce double de la contrainte qui a été
rappelée juste avant des FPG
c'est-à-dire de la cotation des
logements qui effectivement peut aboutir
à deux effets le premier c'est la non
mise sur le marché
donc on accroît l'état de tension sur le
marché immobilier sur nos territoires
et le deuxième c'est l'absence de
réponse financière au niveau de
cet enjeu donc clairement on n'a pas de
visibilité de moyens long terme sur les
politiques publiques qui seront nés en
matière donc vous avez des gens qui
souhaiteraient pouvoir continuer de
mettre sur leur marché leurs biens et
qui ne savent pas ce qui va se passer
d'autant vous vous avez tous perçu ça il
faut de trois ans pour obtenir une
rénovation énergétique entre le premier
mouvement qui consiste à aller voir un
conseil et la finalisation du dossier ça
se double sur les territoires des
difficultés de répondre de réponse des
entreprises soit par absence de
compétences soit par surcroît de travail
donc on est sur un ensemble en fait qui
du coup
nécessite dans un premier temps un
renforcement de l'accompagnement alors
je reviens au guichet unique qui serait
qui serait une bonne chose mais quand on
regarde un peu dans le détail on
s'aperçoit de quoi on s'aperçoit qu'on a
la ma prime rénove qu'on a laissé deux
œufs alors déjà bien malin quel citoyen
pourra s'y retrouver dans ce dispositif
les C2E de manière j'allais dire
complètement hors sol par rapport à tous
les cas la compréhension du citoyen en
plus elles sont présentées par les
entreprises ou par le Conseil dans le
meilleur des cas donc voilà il y a il y
a cet effet là
et d'autre part
autre point important dans la démarche
du citoyen c'est la non garantie de
l'atteinte du résultat
cette non garantie de l'atteinte des
résultats elle est liée à quoi elle est
liée alors je sais pas prendre
difficulté des entreprises à être à la
hauteur etc etc mais elle est liée aussi
au fait que
le citoyen
ne dispose pas de démons de vérification
neutre de sa situation alors on dit à
chaque fois que je dis ça ouais mais il
y a les fait rebond ok il y a l'effet
rebond pour ceux qui sont par exemple
des précaires ils vont se mieux chauffer
et c'est une bonne chose donc il y a cet
aspect là mais il y a surtout le fait
que et ça c'est plus général quand on
délivre un permis de construire une
autorisation de travaux il n'y a pas de
vérification possible de la part des
collectivités donc et ça c'est un sujet
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui quelque
part la collectivité lorsqu'elle délivre
le permis de construire ou
l'autorisation de travaux finalement
quelque part elle garantit le résultat
c'est-à-dire qu'elle a regardé je dis
pas que c'est la réalité mais puisqu'on
garantit rien en réalité mais en tous
les cas on se dit tiens c'est bon je
suis passé par les fourches codines
d'une institution qui connaît le sujet
de ce sujet ce qui est je dis nexte mais
en plus on peut pas vérifier donc du
coup la situation est quand même
pas évidente pour nous sur ce terrain
peut-être dernier élément parce que il y
a beaucoup de choses qui peuvent qui
peuvent être dites sur ce sujet mais je
voulais insister sur
le financement
le Sénat la voté il y a quelques années
je crois deux reprises d'ailleurs c'est
l'atterritorialisation de la
contribution climat énergie
c'est un élément qui est un élément
important important pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que ça
pourrait donner du sens à l'action
c'est-à-dire que c'est bien le citoyen
qui paie cette taxe et donc on lui
dirait il y a un retour finalement sur
ce que vous êtes amené à
contribuer la deuxième chose donc
au-delà de du sens premier que je viens
d'indiquer la deuxième chose c'est le
fait que on aurait de la visibilité du
financement j'ai insisté déjà un peu
dessus mais je crois qu'il faut y
revenir et puisque les opérations sont
particulièrement longues
et enfin ça permettrait aux
collectivités de mettre les moyens pour
accompagner de manière sérieuse les
porteurs de projet
et aujourd'hui puisque je représente
France urbaine donc à les priori les
grandes collectivités qui ont quelques
moyens on constate quoi en réalité c'est
que nous n'avons pas non plus les moyens
à la hauteur des enjeux sur un
territoire qui comporte plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'habitants donc
voilà je veux dire c'est oui il y a plus
de moyens mais l'enjeu est d'autant plus
important
enfin
moi je crois que si on devait avancer
sur ce sujet il faudrait en réalité et
c'est pour globaliser et conclure il
faudra en réalité instituer un tiers de
confiance dans tout ce dispositif
alors est-ce que ce doit être l'état
est-ce que ce doit être la collectivité
elle-même en tous les cas
c'est
si on veut être à la hauteur c'est un
financement et de la confiance et je
crois que les deux aujourd'hui ne sont
pas présents
merci beaucoup monsieur le
vice-président madame la vice-présidente
au nom d'intercommunalité de France
oui merci merci de nous exprimer sur ce
beau sujet de l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique
c'est un sujet qui avait effectivement
est très vraiment d'actualité et
nous presse et on voit bien que malgré
pourtant des années et des années de
réflexion sur ce sur ce sujet là on a du
mal à avancer donc j'ai également en
complément de mes deux collègues qui
viennent de présenter leur vision
intercommunalité de France
en fait on
voudrait partir surtout de la vision
déjà des des habitants et bien sûr des
élus qui ont qui sont la main dans le
mode les mains dans le moteur et qui à
chaque fois ne trouvent pas toujours les
réponses à leurs questionnements
les réductions de consommation
énergétiques des bâtiments bien entendu
on est d'accord répondre à des enjeux
environnementaux financiers sociaux je
vais pas tout vous les donner mais ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que dans les
territoires aujourd'hui les habitants
quand ils veulent habiter quelque part
ils regardent à la fois l'achat
l'acquisition du bien ou même s'ils sont
locataires ils voient la chose en même
temps c'est à dire à la fois le droit
d'aller dans un endroit habité mais
aussi le coût énergétique derrière c'est
vraiment un paquet c'est ensemble
maintenant il y a des personnes qui ont
des logements vacants des propriétaires
qui ont des logements vacants parce
qu'ils n'ont pas fait non plus ces
efforts de rénovation donc effectivement
cette question de réduction des
consommations d'énergie dans les
bâtiments ça interroge aussi cette
question des logements vacants on en a
beaucoup donc ça interroge la
revitalisation des centres Bours que ça
soit en rural ou en
urbain parce que dans des centres
urbains on a aussi beaucoup de logements
vacants qui correspondent plus trop plus
trop aux attentes aussi ça voilà ça ne
correspond pas uniquement que les
passoires thermiques
s'interroge aussi
toutes les questions des pluies et des
de la loizanne parce que quelque part
quand on s'est engagé à l'échelle d'une
intercommunalité à avoir un pays lui
ambitieux pour
économe en consommation de fonciers ou
si vraiment on est complètement à fond
derrière la loizanne derrière il faut
proposer des solutions et aujourd'hui
les solutions qu'on propose ne sont pas
assez accessibles aux habitants aux
artisans et aux collectivités pour
qu'elles soient efficace donc en fait au
niveau d'intercommunalité de France nous
on milite vraiment on accompagne depuis
de longues années la rénovation des
logements auprès des enfin l'engagement
dans ces politiques mais cette politique
elle est très complexes et donc on a
besoin de simplicité de transparence du
conseil d'une approche globale et aussi
que les collectivités s'engagent dans
l'exemplarité en fait si on veut
entraîner les propriétaires si on veut
entraîner les habitants si on veut
entraîner c'est une question
d'entraînement c'est un peu comme toutes
séquence question de transition il faut
qu'on entraîne une collectivité un
territoire dans cette démarche et pour
entraîner des fois faut pas toujours
passer par la case rénovation
énergétique c'est pour ça que lorsqu'on
a du conseil
sur des plateformes par exemple nous on
a constaté moi je parle plus à l'échelle
d'un territoire rural c'est la
communauté de communes dans laquelle
subissent présidente et anciennement
présidente on a vraiment travaillé sur
cette question dans une communauté
rurale normande donc avec toute la
question de du bâti de la reconstruction
oui tout ce que ça peut les passoires
thermiques et la zone envie de vivre
dans ces bâtiments là et qu'on trouve
pas joli alors que respectueux de façon
architecturale il y a plein de d'intérêt
mais bon je passe donc voilà on a besoin
de dans toutes ces politiques de
transition on a besoin
d'emmener du monde en fait dans cette
réflexion donc quand on va parler par
exemple prestige restriction de terrain
constructible moi je sais que quand on
avait fait ça dans le pays on s'était
dit il faut qu'on ait une solution et
cette solution il faut qu'elle soit
simple de mise en oeuvre mais ça
nécessite d'avoir des moyens techniques
et humains dans les collectivités pour
animer pour garantir cette transparence
en fait de conseils et quelquefois par
exemple ça va être on va y arriver par
des personnes qui veulent tout
simplement mettre aux normes du
vieillissement enfin l'accessibilité de
leur logement et finalement ils vont
arriver à un projet de rénovation
globale oui c'est ce que je veux je
m'exprime là dessus parce que on
constate régulièrement que par un petit
bout de la lorgnette finalement on
arrive à faire une rénovation qui tient
la route mais pour ça il faut qu'on ait
des
âges on a des difficultés de recrutement
c'est vraiment ce qu'on veut
faire remonter aussi aujourd'hui les
communautés de communes ou les
collectivités en général ont des
difficultés de recrutement nous par
exemple sur notre plateforme ça fait
trois agents alors à chaque fois quand
vous avez une personne qui sait bien
engagé et qui passe bien pauvre bon on a
besoin d'avoir on a des difficultés de
recrutement on a des difficultés
d'agents qui sont qui soient
suffisamment formés pour porter ces
plateformes ou ses endroits alors on
peut les je sais pas comment on peut les
appeler c'est guichet unique c'est
guichet d'accueil et d'orientation parce
que c'est bien d'en faire partout très
bien mais il faut qu'il puisse être
animé avec des compétences et des gens
qui s'impliquent et qui restent sur les
territoires puisque comme on l'a très
bien dit auprès des sœurs c'est qu'il y
a c'est du temps long c'est du temps
long il faut convaincre
aujourd'hui par exemple la question de
la location des locations avec des
exigences de normes énergétiques dans
mon territoire je le dis très clairement
on a beaucoup de gens qui vendent donc
ça ça fait une pression supplémentaire
sur l'accessibilité au logement ça fait
une pression supplémentaire sur sur le
champ locatif ça c'est très clair donc
il faut pouvoir faciliter ces conseils
auprès des des citoyens et la deuxième
chose qui me semble importante c'est la
question alors vous avez parlé de
l'unicité des démarches
les territoires sont très divers
et pour vraiment que ça soit efficace il
faut que le la collectivité porteuse de
ce projet
est quand même un diagnostic assez fin
et puisse élaborer une stratégie qui
soit adaptée à son territoire je vais
reprendre mon histoire des logements de
la reconstruction il y en a pas partout
des logements de la reconstruction par
exemple et ça il y a vraiment des des
questions très pointues très précises
très particulière il y a aussi une
culture je pense que les Normands ils
vont pas aborder la question de la
rénovation énergétique comme les
Franc-Comtois bon voilà c'est c'est il y
a cette question là qu'il faut et on a
besoin d'avoir une certaine souplesse
pour pouvoir mettre en place une
stratégie qui soit efficace donc il faut
vraiment qu'il y ait une co-construction
je dis pas qui au niveau
d'interconnemunalité c'est pas l'idée
que
tout soit porté par l'intercommunalité
mais qu'il y ait un travail de
co-construction avec l'État et les
communes la communauté de commune et
d'autres d'autres acteurs sur ce qu'on
veut faire sur notre territoire et
comment on veut comment on veut le
fabriquer finalement cette cette
investissement
et pour terminer voilà et donc
sur l'exemplarité là aussi on aurait
besoin pour pouvoir engager ces
démontrer que c'est possible qu'il y ait
des un accompagnement particulier auprès
des communes qui s'engagent à faire du
logement locatif dans des bâtiments ou
dans des des
logements vacants par exemple qui
puissent s'engager à acheter parce que
aujourd'hui on a un problème alors il
est peut-être plus rural qu'urin vous
allez me le dire c'est par exemple nous
on a MANCHE HABITAT bon ça peut être
n'importe quel organisme de logement
sociaux il sont très frileux de venir
rénover du logement vacant dans des
collectivités donc aujourd'hui c'est des
communes des fois petite qui s'engagent
moi je suis maire de ma commune j'ai 730
habitants j'ai 10 logements
ils sont toujours loués parce qu'on a
investi etc bon et il faudrait pouvoir
avoir des des espaces démonstratifs à
l'échelle des communes ou des
communautés de communes pour que tout le
monde s'y mettre quoi et puis qu'on
puisse le faire collectivement donc ce
besoin de simplicité ce besoin de
transparence du conseil il est très
important et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on veut vraiment que la
politique continue à avoir bien ces
valeurs là
dans les futurs projets de
d'accompagnement de rénovation
voilà pour ce qui concerne
l'intercommunalité merci Madame la
vice-présidente nous allons laisser la
parole à Monsieur le Délégué Général
d'amorce merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente d'avoir je dois excuser
Michel Maya qui est le vice-président en
charge de la rénovation énergétique au
sein d'un Morse qui n'était pas
disponible aujourd'hui que je remplace
je voudrais peut-être commencer par un
propos liminaire en disant effectivement
et je crois que vous l'avez également
suggéré dans vos propos on vit une sorte
de transition énergétique un peu en
trompe l'oeil et une forme de
d'amélioration de l'efficacité
énergétique du bâti du logement qui est
l'un des grands blocs c'est le principal
poste de consommation avec les
transports du pays également trompe
l'oeil deux chiffres pour pour
l'illustrer d'abord la consommation
finale d'énergie pour le résidentiel ne
bouge pas depuis près de 20 ans on
tourne autour de 500 terawatt-heure
d'énergie finale ça s'explique aussi par
le fait qu'on a des nouveaux usages de
l'énergie on a tous une tablette
quelques ordinateurs mais globalement on
assiste pas une baisse de la
consommation dans nos maisons et dans
nos logements deuxième élément la
rénovation j'allais dire chiffrer c'est
à peu près 700 000 rénovations chiffres
officiel 718 je crois mais elle elle
cache une réalité plus plus préoccupante
d'une part la plupart de ces de ces de
ces rénovations sont en fait des
rénovations dites monogestes donc en
réalité on aurait une offre que très
partitionnement l'habitat et et la
plupart de ces monogènes sont en fait
des changements de chauffage
et la plupart de ces changements de
chauffage sont en fait aujourd'hui des
pompes à chaleur et je vais précis
puisque vous avez demandé de pas mentir
je ne parle pas de toutes les pompes à
chaleur je parle uniquement des pompes à
chaleur RR ou ro qui aujourd'hui
devienne un véritable problème et je
leur ai l'occasion de vous en reparler
car les chiffres j'ai pas l'occasion de
vous passer des slides mais vous verriez
ce qui est aujourd'hui le mix de
chauffage français il y a une courbe qui
est en train de
de dépasser toutes les autres c'est la
pompe à chaleur RR uniquement donc il
faut se poser la question de cet outil
là il s'agit pas de diaboliser mais de
leur mettre à sa juste place donc ces
deux chiffres sont importants on ne
baisse pas la consommation d'énergie du
logement et aujourd'hui la rénovation se
fait monogeste sur du chauffage il y a
aussi pas mal de poils à bois pour un
tout à fenêtre dans ces monogestes
deuxième élément la grille de lecture de
votre réflexion elle est complexe parce
qu'en réalité il y a il y a une
discussion à voir sur le 9 et l'existant
se pose par exemple on en parle pas
beaucoup mais la manière dont finalement
la R20 est appliquée ou pas je parle
même pas de la reverva était-elle bien
élaboré ou pas parce qu'en fait en
réalité elle a été probablement un peu
orientée sur les questions de CO2 à
juste titre mais ça a probablement
biaisé une partie des débats par exemple
sur le chauffage électrique il y a une
deuxième question qui est se passe-t-il
la même chose dans le logement
individuel dans le logement collectif
public dans lesquels les élus ont plus
de prises parce qu'il y a les bailleurs
sociaux ou la copropriété privée il se
passe pas tout à fait la même chose
il se passe aussi des choses différentes
selon que le propriétaire est occupant
le propriétaire et bailleur il se passe
pas non plus la même chose si le
propriétaire est précaire et Jean
Patrick pinson donc il y a une j'allais
dire aborder ce sujet mais mérite un peu
de méthode je vous invite à faire un
grand tableau il a peut-être un peu
voilà avec différentes entrées selon
qu'on évoque ces différents sujets se
pose aussi forcément la question je
provoquer de l'enveloppe et des usages
de l'énergie dans ces questions
d'efficacité dans le logement et puis
peut-être je prends un petit peu de
hauteur finalement la question qu'on
peut se poser sur un c'est un marché
énergétique c'est un marché de la
construction et en même temps l'intérêt
général via l'État via les collectivités
essaient de d'orienter la manière ça se
passe et finalement une autre question
qui peut se poser de manière
intéressante c'est à quel point le
marché influe la trajectoire à quel
point j'allais dire le service public au
sens très large l'État les collectivités
locales arrivent à leur réorienter de
manière à ce qu'ils ne prennent pas une
mauvaise direction et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la situation est
compliquée enfin je vais peut-être pas
rentrer dans les détails de la crise
énergétique mais une crise énergétique
c'est un phénomène de marché qui a
beaucoup influé sur la sobriété et la
preuve et vous imaginez bien pas que je
suis en train de pas de je suis pas en
train de chanter la gloire de la crise
énergétique et du marché mais c'est vrai
que le risque d'augmentation des prix et
le risque de blackout qui sont aussi un
phénomène de marché je crois que vous
avez auditionné un certain nombre
d'opérateurs récemment a provoqué une
sobriété elle est elle est je crois que
là je je prends pas de risque en disant
il y a eu best et consommation entre 9
et 13%. donc on a aussi des phénomènes
qui sont à prendre en compte dans la
manière dont une politique publique peut
être menée et pour les réguler et pour
les réguler très clairement
à ce stade je voulais vraiment insister
sur le fait que le processus qui ferait
une bonne efficacité énergétique dans le
logement en particulier dans le domaine
de la rénovation c'est d'abord la
formation ensuite la sensibilisation
ensuite l'accompagnement ensuite
accompagnement technique ensuite les
aides et les financements ensuite des
formes de coercition on en reparlera
et ensuite une forme de contrôle et une
fois que cette chaîne est en place cette
chaîne de vertu est en place on peut
imaginer atteindre notre objectif
sur l'information
je crois que ça a été dit par Jean
Patrick et puis par qui Geoffroy
également mais on a un déficit
d'information d'abord en tant qu'usage
je vais pas vous faire l'offense de vous
demander à combien était votre compteur
électrique hier soir alors que je pense
que je peux vous faire l'offense de vous
demander quand c'est combien consomme
votre voiture je pense que vous savez
répondre à la deuxième question je ne
sais même pas répondre à la première
personnellement ça peut vous rassurer je
dis ça parce que on a des élus pour vous
montrer un peu que les élus se laissent
prennent le sujet en main le maire de
Villefranche en Beaujolais de pardon à
de belles villes en Beaujolais a annoncé
hier la distribution de compteurs
visuel au ménage de sa ville ce sont des
petits compteurs qui fonctionnent en
télé-relle qui ne sont pas qui sont liés
au Linky mais le Linky il se voulait
intelligent mais il est pas très visible
il est pas très donc en fait vous avez
ce petit compteur que vous pouvez mettre
de vote devant votre plaque de de votre
plaque de cuisson devant votre devant
votre de votre chauffage etc et vous
voyez les euros et les utilisateur
bouger en même temps que vous montez
d'un degré voilà une forme de j'allais
dire de premier niveau d'information le
jour où les Français sauront ce qu'il
consomme et ce qu'il paye quasiment de
jour en jour ça changera complètement la
relation à l'énergie comme vous savez à
peu près ce que vous payez de carburant
premièrement deuxième élément
d'information plutôt collectivité locale
on a fait un pas gigantesque avec ce
qu'on appelle l'article 179 de la loi
ltecv c'est qu'on a donné aux
collectivités locales les principales
données de consommation des bâtiments
sur leur territoire c'est un lapin
important mais il est insuffisant parce
qu'en réalité on s'est limité à 10
points de livraison 10 points de
livraison c'est à la fois beaucoup parce
que ça permet de d'avoir accès à aux
données de d'immeubles R3 R4 R5 on va
dire mais en fait on n'a pas les données
en dessous alors que par exemple après
karité énergétique se fait beaucoup dans
le logement individuel il nous faut les
donner de ses consommations donc
aujourd'hui on est obligé de passer par
des circonvolutions en particulier par
les CCAS et les FSL pour récupérer la
consommation de la personne qui arrive
pas à payer de lui demander pour éviter
la CNIL de vous autoriser à utiliser sa
donnée enfin c'est très compliqué pour
une collectivité finalement
d'appréhender la consommation d'énergie
de son territoire et donc il faut aller
plus loin dans cet accès à la donnée
première élément deuxième élément
d'information c'est effectivement France
Renov c'est un service public on a
appelé sur vice-publique d'efficacité
énergétique je serai plus modeste on est
dans un service public d'information à
l'efficacité énergétique on ne fait que
la première brique du processus et de la
chaîne virtuce que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure cette chaîne aujourd'hui elle
fonctionne elle est là sur tout le
territoire c'est quand même une vraie
réussite collective maintenant elle a
ses limites d'abord ça sera intéressant
moi j'ai pas les chiffres de savoir
combien de personnes ont été en contact
avec France rénov et combien de
personnes ont été en contact avec des
démarcheurs le samedi et le dimanche
je crains que le deuxième chiffre soit
plus important que le premier et c'est
des marcheurs ne disent pas la vérité
eux donc on a besoin à la fois de
booster cette capacité d'intervention y
compris par du contact à domicile Guy et
jean-Patrique connaissent bien les
ambassadeurs du tri on n'a jamais
imaginé à les frapper aux portes ou
encore que quelques collectivités en
fait mais à un moment donné il faut
aller vers les gens on peut pas rester
derrière des guichets et aujourd'hui on
est quand même dans une logique de
guichet donc on a une amie donc il faut
vraiment booster ce France rénov premier
sujet puis le deuxième c'est que France
rénov va être d'abord été fait pour
parler d'enveloppe non pas qu'il ne doit
s'en dessaisir mais il est temps que
France rénov parle de chauffage il est
temps que France rénov parle de
comportement au passage je dis ça mais
un certain nombre de points
d'informations le font mais c'est pas
systémique et c'est pas dans le cahier
des charges il faut à la fois parler de
l'enveloppe mais il faut être capable
par exemple vous appeler un France rénov
quelque part en France vous leur
demandez comment il faut se chauffer
comment il faut se chauffer une fois que
j'ai réglé le problème de l'enveloppe il
y en a deux sur trois qui ne répondent
pas à cette question ou qui répondent de
manière très parcellaire par exemple on
a fait le test la quasi-totalité ne
parle pas de réseau de chaleur
qui est quand même l'outil public local
que nous avons à la disposition pour
chauffer moins cher moins carbonée
renouvelable local et France rénov n'en
parle pas donc il faut élargir le champ
de France rénov deuxième élément
important de notre point de vue c'est
effectivement la
compagnement donc vous avez posé une
question très précise sur la
compagnateur Renov c'est là aussi une
avancée c'est à dire jusqu'ici le marché
y compris avec des contrats j'allais
dire d'intéressement d'un certain nombre
d'opérateurs de chauffage vis-à-vis de
typologie ou de d'équipements de
chauffage faisait que une fois que vous
aviez un professionnel chez vous il y en
avait un sur deux qui vous disaient
peut-être pas la totalité des solutions
mais qui orientait la solution enfin en
faveur de telles solutions dans l'Ancien
Monde mettez une chaudière à
condensation gaz ça vous coûtera moins
cher dans le Nouveau Monde mettez une
pompe à chaleur RR donc France rénov
enfin l'accompagnateur en off c'est
quand même un premier élément
intéressant c'est quand même un
encadrement de la capacité à intervenir
maintenant on trouve que c'est quand
même un peu frustrant parce que d'une
part on a un peu l'impression qu'on va
donner j'allais dire le titre
accompagnateur rénov à peu près tout le
monde les conditions de dans sont
importantes et puis surtout il y a pas
de connexion réelle ou en tout cas on
nous l'a pas précisé à ce stade entre
France rénov et accompagnateur Renov
nous ce qu'on aimerait à minima c'est
qu'il y a un SAV c'est à dire que une
fois que vous êtes passé par la
compagnateur Renov et la possibilité de
retourner à France rénov pour dire voilà
ce que finalement l'accompagnateur rénov
me propose est-ce que vous trouvez ça
cohérent par rapport à ce que vous
m'avez dit quand je vous ai vu la
première fois mais de manière générale
une autre option plus plus ambitieuse
serait que ce soit les collectivités
locales qui coordonnent la campagnateur
rénov puisqu'il fait l'information il
doit être aussi en capacité
d'accompagner la mise en œuvre de ce qui
a été dit aux populations là ça nous
amène dans des débats plus compliqués y
compris financiers
dernière élément
sur l'accompagnement il y a un
accompagnement très spécifique à faire
sur les précaires et aujourd'hui on
pense que la compagnateur Renov ne le
fera pas naturellement donc je pense que
l'État on a aussi conscience mais il
faut vraiment qu'on mette en place cela
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que amorce et
Jean Patrick pourrait en parler il a il
a il a expérimenté le dispositif à créer
un programme s'appelle pas de -15 qui
visait à accompagner à identifier des
profils très spécifiques de précaires il
y a des précaires qui ont les moyens de
faire un peu de rénovation il y a des
précaires qui sont incapables de payer
un euro de race à charge les
accompagnent il y a des précaires qui
sont plus en situation de réaliser ces
travaux eux-mêmes il faut les
accompagner de AZ il y en a d'autres qui
sont plus autonome etc il y a des
précaires dans du logement locatif et
des propriétaires donc il faut vraiment
qu'on affine cet accompagnement des
précaires et je crois que Lana on a on a
aussi besoin parce que on s'est rendu
compte par ces je parle sous ton
contrôle de Jean Patrick mais on s'est
rendu compte que ce programme
identifié et accompagné des précaires
qui étaient sous les radars
principalement que que Lana ne voyait
pas que Lana ne voyait pas arriver
ensuite il y a la question des aides et
des financements et ça a été dit par
d'autres mais le dispositif est à la
fois bien fait mais aussi très orienté
ma prime rénove aujourd'hui être
principalement des pompes à chaleur et
des choses des poêles à bois on a donc
pas trouvé complètement le rythme de
croisière d'une mapping Renov qui est
capable d'aider la rénovation
énergétique et encore moins la
rénovation énergétique collective
puisque vous le savez vous avez les
chiffres la rénovation dans le logement
collectif fonctionne pas ou peu 25000
rénovations maximum là on a des
questions de prise de décision pour ceux
qui ont déjà participé à au plaisir de
participer à une assemblée de
copropriétaires mais comprenez bien la
difficulté de prendre ce type de
décision quand on est à peine capable de
prendre des décisions sur un changement
de paillasson c'est du vécu donc là il
faut vraiment complètement changer le
processus de décision d'une copro mais
aussi d'accompagnement en matière d'aide
effectivement ça a été dit c'est que les
aides aujourd'hui en particulier les
aides sont principalement étaniques les
collectivités ont quasiment pas de prise
on nous dit vous avez les aides à Pierre
mais les aides à Pierre on est opérateur
on est on est on n'a pas le droit de les
orienter donc notre volonté c'est de
pouvoir orienter c'est c'est vraiment
une délégation et pas et pas juste une
délégation d'opération quoi donc ça
c'est un premier point et probablement
qu'il y a d'autres dispositifs à mettre
en place par rapport à ça certains élus
je
suppose aussi la question d'un malus de
taxe foncière également dans des choses
comme ça qui permettraient de dire les
FP léger on est on est légitime à à
oser à permettre à permettre par imposer
mais à permettre une un malus de taxe
foncières bien sûr adaptée à différents
de situations en matière de coercition
c'est vrai que finalement
mère d'une grande agglomération le
président une grande agglomération a dit
à quelques années sans coercition les
aide ça finit par coûter très cher
effectivement si on ne fait que aider
c'est difficile c'est pour ça que l'idée
de d'un horizon de coercition on est à
l'origine du fameux amendement sur les
passoires thermiques dans la loi de CV
des débats sur le Conseil
constitutionnel le Conseil
constitutionnel a failli éliminer la
mesure on est passé tout près de
l'élimination de cette mesure
aujourd'hui on aura mis 10 ans à la
mettre en place mais finalement elle va
elle va commencer à rendre son office on
voit quand même les la l'échéance se
rapprocher avec avec les défauts qu'elle
a et je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails mais c'est vrai que finalement
on le voit aussi nous dans les
collectivités sur le décrétaire c'est
sûr que ça nous donne quand même une
échéance ça nous challenge un peu quand
même même s'il est pas parfait lui non
plus donc on pense qu'il faut des des
horizons de coercition en particulier
sur les copropriétés parce que sinon ça
n'avancera pas et il faut oser ces
périodes intermédiaires qui ont été
plutôt bien faites d'ailleurs de
d'interdiction d'augmentation de des
loyers qui étaient une sorte de premier
coup de semence avant l'interdiction de
logement donc il faut cette horizon
coercition dans tous ces domaines là
sinon sinon on n'arrivera pas à
embarquer tout le monde et par contre il
faut entre l'horizon de coercition et
maintenant il y a des aides qui
permettent quand même aux gens de faire
parce que si on leur donne des aides
insuffisantes et c'est le cas pour un
certain nombre précaires ils vont
prendre le mur de la coercition c'est à
dire l'interdiction de de vivre dans ces
logements là
il se pose aussi pour nous une question
de savoir si nos outils planification
sont suffisamment efficaces faut être
honnête on va pas se mentir un pcaet sa
capacité à provoquer de la rénovation et
proche de zéro un PLH j'en suis pas sûr
que ce soit beaucoup plus et un PLU
n'intervient pas et c'est bien d'aller
le drame du PLU c'est qu'il est capable
d'imposer quelque chose à quelqu'un qui
fait si vous voulez faire une véranda on
vous donnera les conditions dans
lesquelles vous faites mais il est
incapable ou presque d'imposer des
choses à quelqu'un qui ne bouge pas qui
est dans son logement et qui est sous FG
donc on a une difficulté c'est que le
PLU est très bien pour intervenir
lorsqu'on fait mais pas lorsque il faut
faire et qu'on ne fait pas donc là on a
on a un sujet qui est pas totalement
stabilisé entre nous mais on sent que
nos outils de planification et le plus
coercitif c'est quand même le PLU
n'arrive pas à impacter ces éléments là
cela dit je vous invite à regarder le
projet fit for fifty-five de l'Europe
qui introduit l'idée de plantes
territoriale chaleur
qui nous paraît intéressant parce que de
même que vous avez des PDUs il est
probable que l'autre grande consommation
d'énergie qui est le chauffage en fait
pourrait faire l'objet j'allais dire
d'une pourrait être l'objet d'une
planification propre avec des moyens de
coercition ça m'oblige aussi à vous dire
et ça me fera la transition avec la
future loi que vous allez voir puisque
finalement vous allez où nous allons
avoir une loi de programmation de
l'énergie maintenant ça a été confirmé
par le gouvernement c'est ce qu'on a
compris la semaine dernière de la
première ministre
nous espérons ça serment qu'il y aura un
chapitre consacré à la chaleur au
chauffage et un autre sur les transports
il faut qu'on sorte d'un débat sur
comment produire l'électricité on s'est
mortifère de se poser que cette question
de comment produit l'électricité et je
mets je renvoie dos à dos les
pro-éoliens et les produits clairs c'est
pas le sujet le sujet c'est comment
chauffer comment se déplace dans ce pays
et comment on réduit cette consommation
vous voyez on se fait 20 ans qu'on se
pose la question de savoir comment
produire électricité résultat la
consommation d'énergie dans le logement
n'a pas bougé
on a bougé notre mix énergétique mais la
consommation d'énergie dans le logement
n'a pas bougé donc je vous invite à
avoir un vrai chapitre sur comment se
chauffe le pays et un vrai chapitre sur
comment il se il se transporte une
dernière question qui est quand même
aussi posée c'est le contrôle la
capacité de contrôle aujourd'hui d'une
collectivité locale sur ce qui est
construit ou sur ce qui est rénové et
proche de 0 et la capacité de l'État
guerre meilleur donc on a vraiment
besoin de régler ça parce que on l'a vu
ce sujet d'ailleurs je vais peut-être
faire une petite petite parenthèse sur
la question de la pompe à chaleur
pourquoi on en parle tous parce que là
on tient un sujet qui va qui va être
véritable carnage dans les 20 prochaines
années et encore une fois on ne parle
pas de toutes les pompes à chaleur les
pompes à chaleur et eau sont des vrais
hauts sont des vrais dispositifs
efficaces mais une pompe à chaleur si
vous en connaissez le principe c'est le
cycle de Carnot vous prenez de l'air
dans l'atmosphère et vous le compressez
avec une énergie si l'air est à 15 la
montée à 25 pour vous chauffer ça me
consomme pas beaucoup d'énergie mais si
l'air est à zéro c'est pas de chance
c'est en hiver qu'on se chauffe elle
consomme beaucoup d'énergie on est
proche à certains radiateur électrique
on est proche de ce qu'on appelle COP 1
donc
se pose deux questions un peu
fondamentales est-ce qu'il faut
considérer une pompe à chaleur rere
comme un outil d'énergie renouvelable de
notre point de vue comme l'a été
autrefois les co-générations gaz est
plutôt un outil d'efficacité énergétique
ça doit permettre lorsqu'elle sont
bonnes d'économiser de l'énergie mais ce
n'est pas un outil d'énergie
renouvelable puisque ça concerne
principalement une électricité qui dans
ce pays n'est pas renouvelable je
rappelle que la part d'énergie
renouvelable dans l'électricité c'est
20% et puis deuxième élément c'est
doit-elle être aidé à ce point alors on
a réussi déjà enlevé les ma prime ma
prime rénov mais restent des C2E et puis
les pompes à chaleur ro n'ont pas des
performances guerre meilleur donc ça
pose vraiment une question il faut
vraiment s'emparer de ce seul sujet des
pompes à chaleur y compris pour trier le
bon grain de livret il y a vraiment des
très bonnes pompes à chaleur il y a même
de très bonnes pompes à chaleur roi avec
des cops de qualité plus de cas plus de
5 celle-ci doivent être aidés mais il
faut absolument mettre des critères
d'efficacité énergétique sur la pompe à
chaleur on est en train de rééquiper la
France de l'équivalent de radiateur
électrique en particulier dans le
logement social ma prime rénov c'est des
pompes à chaleur on va donner à des
logements sociaux des on commence à
avoir des impayés et on commence à avoir
des des dysfonctionnements sur ces
outils là donc il est temps de réguler
et d'arrêter de voir des publicités
cryant moins émerveilles sur cet outil
de chauffage qui n'en est pas
systématiquement un bon loin de là au
passage je suis obligé de le dire c'est
le côté un peu
politiquement incorrect d'amorce ça fait
un peu partie de notre ADN mais l'État
n'est pas totalement net dans cette
histoire je vous rappelle que l'État
français est quand même un peu jugé
parti sur ces histoires d'électricité il
est à la fois normalement le garant de
l'intérêt général il a intérêt à ce que
les populations consomment et finalement
on a l'impression que le l'histoire
qu'il a envie de nous raconter
aujourd'hui dans la loi de transition
énergétique c'est ça n'est pas une
transition énergétique c'est une
transition électrique puisque au passage
est probablement sain il est
probablement nécessaire qu'un certain
nombre d'usages passe à l'électricité
qui en grande partie des carbonées mais
attention à ne pas louper le rendez-vous
avec l'efficacité énergétique et
aujourd'hui on le voit à ma prime rénove
aide d'abord des outils de produits de
chauffage électrique avant d'outils
d'aider des outils de rénovation
énergétique et d'efficaces énergétique
et donc il y a un risque là on en
reparlera peut-être qu'il y a des
auditions sur la loi que on passe tout à
l'électricité que d'une part
l'électricité coûte beaucoup plus cher
que d'autre part on n'est pas les moyens
de la produire vous savez que le parc
nucléaire à venir il arrive dans 15 ans
on a 15 ans à faire 100 le nouveau parc
que
que on se retrouve avec des questions de
pouvoir d'achat de précarité énergétique
et que donc il est probablement temps de
se poser les bonnes questions qui
comment se chauffer comment se
transporter plutôt que comment on
produit l'électricité dans le pays et
j'en finirai par là en 46 général de
Gaulle à mis sur les fonds bâtissements
de service public le service public de
fourniture de distribution d'électricité
en créant EDF et distribution de
distribution et de fourniture du gaz en
créant GDF c'était l'équation de
l'époque c'est à dire il fallait fournir
de l'énergie aux Français dans cette
période de redéploiement économique nous
nous semble que demain c'est tout
l'enjeu de la loi énergie qui arrive
bientôt dans votre hémicycle c'est de
savoir ce qu'est le service public de
l'énergie et de notre point de vue le
service public de l'énergie le 1er c'est
un service public d'efficacité
énergétique donc finalement il faudrait
transformer cette un clin d'oeil à ce
stade EDF en économie d'énergie de
France la vraie le vrai service public
dont on doit créer au regard des enjeux
de climat de pouvoir d'achat de
d'indépendance énergétique de
difficultés de régulation du marché de
l'énergie c'est un service public
d'efficacité énergétique plus de
production et de fournitures peut-être
qu'il faut doter EDF de nouvelles
missions peut-être qu'il faut créer des
opérateurs à côté peut-être qu'il faut
passer par des opérateurs locaux mais le
premier des services publics s'inscrive
d'efficacité qui aujourd'hui n'existe
pas aujourd'hui on est sur des aides et
un service public d'information première
élément le deuxième c'est que le service
public de gaz la plus vraiment d'avenir
gaz n'est pas l'avenir du pays le bioga
sans doute mais le gaz au sens pur n'est
pas alors que les réseaux de chaleur si
les réseaux de chaleur renouvelables si
aujourd'hui nous sommes j'allais dire
submergé de demandes des locaux voulant
créer des réseaux de chaleur mais on en
est encore on est encore loin de la
Généralité il y a près de 300 communes
de 10 à 30000 habitants qui n'ont pas de
réseau de chaleur qui sont aujourd'hui
j'allais dire soumis au marché
d'électricité du gaz pour faire ça y
compris les collectivités qui vous savez
en l'obligation d'acheter d'électricité
sur le marché libre donc il faut
absolument qu'on déploie quelque chose
comme un service public quasi universel
de la chaleur renouvelable ce sont des
ressources locales ce sont de l'économie
locale ce c'est aussi la maîtrise de la
facture
que si vous regardez en dehors du
bouclier tarifaire le réseau de chaleur
renouvelable au bois à la géothermie au
biogaz au solaire thermique à la
récupération d'énergie et le seul qui a
maîtrisé sa facture pendant la crise au
passage il a quand même connu quelques
hausses puisqu'il y avait un peu de gaz
en appoint pour être tout à fait honnête
mais c'est le seul qui l'a fait et puis
effectivement le dernier élément c'est
de savoir où on met si on arrive à faire
un service public de résorption de la
précarité énergétique parce qu'on a
l'impression que malgré les les
incantations et quelques mesures
législatives importantes on est très
très loin d'avoir résorbé les passoires
thermiques donc ce post finalement la
question de la place du service public
de l'énergie dans le futur de du pays
mais ça c'est la loi énergie qui qui
sera l'occasion d'en reparler
merci Monsieur le Délégué Général merci
aux uns et aux autres et donc je te
laisse la parole à notre rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci à vous
à chacun d'entre vous pour vos
explications en tout cas vos retours
effectivement sur ce sujet complexe des
politiques de rénovation
énergétiques je pense que vous avez bien
balayé l'ensemble des problématiques
qu'on a déjà fait effectivement déjà pu
voir
et notamment à travers ça a été rappelé
différents déplacements et puis
auditions et c'est souvent notamment
avec le déplacement en Isère là sur
les discussions avec avec la lettre pour
voir un petit peu comment justement
localement en tout cas c'est politique
publique pouvait se mettre se mettre en
place
bon moi je partage un grand nombre de ce
qui a été dit à la fois sur toute façon
c'est comment on arrive à la fois sur la
question de visibilité de simplicité ça
on est tous d'accord qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à quelque chose qui soit
oui à la fois simple et et accessible
sur la question de l'indépendance du
conseil et de la confiance ça c'est de
la même manière mais je dirais que ça va
ça va avec de toute façon pour avoir cet
accompagnement et donc la question de la
proximité aussi et donc forcément le
lien le lien au collectivités qui nous
paraît évident
donc moi dans mes dans mes questions en
tout cas peut-être remarque par rapport
à ce que vous avez dit c'est comment
justement vous voyez en fait c'est vrai
qu'on a quand même eu des évolutions sur
le dispositif avec France rénov ma prime
rénov etc où je dirais qu'il y a
peut-être un petit peu plus de
lisibilité sur le cheminement même s'il
y a encore peut-être des beaucoup de
choses à faire mais en tout cas par
rapport à ce qu'on a ce qu'on avait pu
voir ou on commence à sentir un petit
peu un cheminement dans le dans le
parcours mais ma question elle est
peut-être justement comment ce qui est
en train de se mettre en place vous le
voyez avec le lien justement aux
collectivités et notamment ce qu'on peut
peut-être voir sur le fait que on a des
politiques publiques locales qui étaient
mises en place de manière je dirais
indépendante je me rappelle notamment
sur soit tes post-tepcv tout ça qu'on
compte permis de de
mettre des financements et donc de faire
en sorte que des collectivités en fait
s'empare de sujets mettent en place des
plateformes de
rénovation thermique d'accompagnement
les alegues enfin en tout cas on avait
ces dispositifs et on a ses dispositifs
sur certains territoires pas surtout ce
qu'on peut voir quand même c'est que ces
dispositifs là ont quand même des
résultats qui sont plutôt intéressants
parce que justement on a cette proximité
on a ce lien de de confiance on a cette
accompagnement ce qui a été dit aussi
c'est
un petit peu la différenciation enfin en
tout cas l'adaptation en fait à des des
critères des critères locaux
et donc aussi des aides aussi qui
peuvent être ciblées en fonction des
particularités locales quoi et donc
voilà je voulais savoir un petit peu
comment vous voyez justement entre ce
qui pouvait exister et ce qui paraissait
quand même parfois fonctionné et puis du
coup commence tout cela peut s'intégrer
et en tout cas qu'on rajoute pas une
nouvelle couche en fait par rapport à ce
que l'État met en place et comment du
coup on peut arriver à intégrer ces
dispositifs ces dispositifs là
ce qui nécessite peut-être aussi parfois
peut-être de clarifier les compétences
entre compétences de l'intercommunalité
départements région etc pour que on
puisse un petit peu clarifier l'ensemble
de ces de ces dispositifs
ce qui a ce qui arrive aussi ça a été
dit c'est qu'on a d'autres d'autres
aspects et que quand on commence à
parler rénovation thermique forcément
aussi on a déjà parlé mais sur la
question du zan qui est un autre aspect
mais qui quelque part peut être assez
proche en tout cas qui sont des
réflexions assez
communes en tout cas donc voilà du coup
peut-être avoir un petit peu votre
vision par rapport justement entre les
politiques publiques qui sont mises en
place et puisqu'on peut ce qu'on peut
voir et en tout cas l'existence sur les
territoires
ce qui amène aussi à la question de
guichet unique bon parler des
plateformes de rénovation mais de savoir
comment vous voyez les choses est-ce que
le fait justement d'avoir des guichets
uniques mais qui sont uniques par
territoire mais qui peuvent être
différents suivant les territoires je
pense que c'est des choses voilà où
est-ce qu'on veut totalement uniformiser
et puis avoir bon c'est un peu ce que ce
que veut faire avec France rénov mais du
coup avoir cette uniformisation sur
l'ensemble des territoires donc comment
vous voyez peut-être ça peut-être en
même temps est-ce que vous avez aussi
des éléments parce que c'est vrai qu'on
se pose des questions sur les disparités
en tout cas d'intervention pour
l'instant on n'a pas franchement de de
chiffres ou de retour mais entre eux
alors c'est vrai que c'est pas forcément
rural
urbain mais en tout cas entre les
différents typologies que ça soit oui
péril urbains urbain même à l'intérieur
des villes mais en tout cas comment on
avance sur cette rénovation thermique en
fonction des différents
les différentes structures
une question également sur mon acompte
vous l'avez un peu répondu mais sur mon
accompagnateur Renov justement c'est
comment en fait il vient prendre sa
place justement dans ce qui parfois peut
être mis en place sur les collectivités
et est-ce que vous voyez pas un risque
sur le fait qu'en fait l'État prenne ça
en charge du coup pose ce dispositif et
que du coup quelque part en fait les
collectivités des engagent en se disant
bah voilà je l'ai je laisse ça je laisse
ça à l'état et puis et puis bah du coup
on a plus besoin de le faire alors qu'on
pouvait avoir des dispositifs encore une
fois très efficaces sur les sur les
territoires donc comment vous voyez du
coup son intégration en tout cas avec ce
qui pouvait se faire
et puis aussi sur la place des
collectivités sur les questions puisque
ça c'est un autre aspect en tout cas de
de la commission d'enquête c'est la
question des filières et de
l'accompagnement à la fois de
l'accompagnement des entreprises en
termes de formation de formation gérer
globale mais de formation aussi sur des
nouvelles techniques autour du bâtiment
et de nouveaux matériaux et puis sur la
question de la mise en place de filières
sur des matériaux plus locaux
en termes de circuits courts puisqu'on
voit qu'on va avoir toute façon si on
monte en charge une vraie question sur
sur la disponibilité et la production de
matériaux et donc c'est vrai que les
collectivités peuvent avoir aussi cette
part en tout cas sur l'accompagnement et
la mise en place de de ces filières et
puis un dernier petit point sur les
réseaux de chaleur parce que je pense
que c'est aussi un point important
ça permet de dire quelques mots sur la
question effectivement de savoir si on
fait une transition énergétique ou une
transition à une transition électrique
je pense qu'on est en plein dedans c'est
vrai que d'avoir une vision uniquement
carbone en fait forcément ça pousse en
tout cas aller uniquement sur cette
question sur cette question d'électrique
avec tout ce qui a été rappelé comme
comme problème que ça peut poser au bout
du compte et c'est vrai que dans les
dans les solutions qui peuvent
apparaître c'est vrai que la question
des réseaux de chaleur est un dispositif
important enfin en tout cas à la fois
sur leur développement à la fois sur les
possibilités de raccordement et c'est
vrai qu'hier on a auditionné les les
bailleurs sociaux et ils nous faisait
remonter justement puisque c'est vrai
que sur des collectifs il y a pas
beaucoup de solutions notamment la pompe
à chaleur là peut être un problème parce
que l'individuel c'est enfin voilà pour
plein de questions techniques c'est
compliqué et donc du coup le réseau de
chaleur est important mais souvent un
manque d'affin de de communication en
termes de données et de donner à jour
sur les sur les réseaux de chaleur et
qui peuvent être importantes en tout cas
sur leur évolution et notamment aussi en
lien avec les DPE parce que si du coup
les données ne sont pas à jour sur les
réseaux de chaleur bah du coup c'est
défavorable dans les dans les DPE et du
coup ben voilà ça ça peut poser certains
problèmes voilà merci
commencez oui répondre à toutes les
questions probablement non
mais prendre ma modeste par de réponse à
l'ensemble de ces questions fort
nombreuses et effectivement
incontournable
je transformerai certaines réponses en
question d'abord
quand on évoque le guichet unique ça a
été un peu dit tout à l'heure dans les
propos de mes collègues
je suis tenté de poser la question et
puis chez nous pourquoi faire est-ce que
c'est un guichet unique pour informer ça
globalement c'est faire
et il y a des dispositifs on ne l'a pas
évoqué mais je me permets de le faire
qui permettent de rendre les guichets
uniques encore plus uniques je parle le
français
je trouverai pas totalement un seul que
au niveau de l'information et au niveau
du premier accompagnement de nos
concitoyens France service soit un point
d'entrée c'est à dire qu'il y a à
l'intérieur de France service les
dispositifs France rénovs pourquoi pas
et je le dis par expérience tout à fait
assumée avec déjà un recul
l'État en accord avec ma commune a mis
en place un dispositif France service
dont les résultats sont exemplaires
on a vraiment à l'exemple de ce que
ressentent nos concitoyens parce que il
y a une chose qu'on n'a pas dit de qui
est peut-être une tarte à la crème mais
je l'exprime c'est que pour nos
concitoyens
que ce soit l'état que ce soit la Région
le Département la commune
l'intercommunalité nos concitoyens ils
ont des besoins ils ont des problèmes
ils ont des difficultés ils veulent un
interlocuteur public crédible et le
premier interlocuteur public crédible à
leur disposition c'est l'élu locale du
bloc communal et c'est pas du tout
péjoratif à l'égard de nos collègues
conseiller départementaux régionaux ou
élus nationaux j'ai été moi-même élu
national je sais vraiment quelle est la
part des choses et
c'est très important que la puissance
publique au sens le plus large du terme
tel que nous la constituons tous
ensemble soit en réponse immédiate
acceptable au niveau de l'information et
du premier accompagnement et pour ça que
je pose la question du guichet unique il
ne sera efficace qu'à un certain nombre
de conditions un qui soit vraiment
simples d'accès qui soit considérés
comme étant vraiment unique et non pas
un des guichets uniques dont on sait pas
à quoi il correspond s'il y a plusieurs
ni chez unique pour plusieurs problèmes
uniques c'est plus des guichets uniques
c'est une diversité de guichets
spécifiques à la diversité des sujets en
cause donc vraiment ça je voulais le
dire parce que
un des plus gros problèmes j’évoquais de
tort dans mon propos à la potentielle
difficulté lié à la judiciarisation de
la relation entre le locataire et le
propriétaire
nos concitoyens quand ils nous abordent
dans la rue au marché ou quand ils
viennent nous voir dans notre bureau la
première chose qu'il dit c'est qu'on n'y
voit pas clair ils mettent pas en cause
la loyauté et la volonté
des pouvoirs publics d'aller en leur
direction pour répondre à un problème
mais il trouve que ils ont raison que
tout est tellement complexe que les
réponses même les plus simples restent
complexes et ne restent pas accessible
donc vraiment je voulais beaucoup
insister là-dessus je voulais également
permettre de reprendre à des éléments et
donc fournir un élément de réponse
j'ai oublié de le lire tout à l'heure
mais c'est utile que je l'évoque
maintenant sur la capacité de l'économie
à répondre à l'ensemble de ces enjeux
avec deux questions la première la
capacité dans la disponibilité des
ressources humaines et matériels dans un
temps par définition très court
et la deuxième catégorie qui est bien
humaine qui est celle de la lutte contre
tous les effets d'aubaine parce que bien
évidemment bon on a vu
on évoquait
la prime rénove on entend sur toutes les
ondes et on lit sur tous les médias
tous les excès et quand je dis que c'est
quelquefois on voit beaucoup plus loin
tous les scandales liés à ces
détournements de d'aide publique avec
des gens dont le niveau d'honnêteté
s'efface au fur et à mesure pour
rejoindre celui de la franche
malhonnêteté bon il y a ces deux sujets
est-ce que l'économie est capable et
comment peut-elle le devenir et donc
quelle priorité parmi les priorités doit
être donnée à la capacité de l'économie
à être capable et comment éviter
l'ensemble des effets d'aubaine
extrêmement malsain qui
complique encore la lisibilité et donc
la crédibilité du système que l'on met
en place et vous parliez des matériaux
locaux je prends un exemple qui me tient
beaucoup à coeur dans mon beau
département de Seine-et-Marne c'est la
capacité de ce département qui est un
département encore urbain puisque proche
de Paris mais déjà rural parce que lié à
9 départements riverains de province je
crois qu'on est le seul département
français à avoir autant de départements
limitrophes qui sont pour l'essentiel
des départements de province on a une
production de chanvre extrêmement
importante avec une filière qui va se
développer de béton chambré bon
on se trouve dans une volonté exprimée
par de nombreux élus de trouver le moyen
que pour l'ensemble de leurs travaux
pour leur bâtiments publics et pourquoi
pas au-delà pour la construction privée
essayez de donner une priorité à ce
matériau biosourcé
de proximité tout ce qui fait la vertu
de tout ce qui nous apparaît aujourd'hui
et qui est indispensable mais
immédiatement on va bien sûr sur heurter
à d'autres règles qu'il faut respecter
qui nous sont supérieures marcher public
etc donc moi je crois qu'il faut qu'on
trouve le moyen dans le respect des
règles européennes qui s'imposent à nous
et qui font que comme on les
surtranspose toujours on les complexifie
un qu'on trouve le moyen de permettre
aux économies locales de mettre sur le
chantier des disponibilités
tous toutes les ressources dont elles
peuvent disposer
affirmation principe plus simple à poser
car régler j'en conviens mais c'est un
véritable sujet je crois que la question
des ressources en matériaux aidés
ressources en personne physique en
salariés des entreprises avec les
formations vous l'avez évoqué monsieur
le rapporteur à pertinente en
accompagnement c'est un des plus gros
chantiers que nous avons devant nous
sachant que un jour la priorité de
priorité c'est ceci le lendemain c'est
cela on est on est plus à une journée
nationale ou internationale par jour
mais à plusieurs journées nationales ou
internationales par jour et on sait très
bien quelle est la complexité de tout ça
je terminerai mon propos sur sur deux
éléments
qui rajoute de la complexité bien sûr
mais qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit c'est
qu'est-ce que l'on veut vraiment
atteindre comme objectif au travers de
la réflexion engagée et de vos travaux
et de ceux à quoi nous pouvons vous
aider à les mener à bien
on cherche à atteindre plusieurs choses
on cherche à atteindre que
chacun dans notre pays a un logement
décent ça pose le problème du nombre de
logements disponibles et de la qualité
des logements disponibles déjà pas
simple que ça coûte le moins cher
possible à chacun et que chacun puisse
se chauffer comme il convient puisse
utiliser les moyens à sa disposition
comme il convient qu'il n'y ait pas de
précarité d'usage de la vie quotidienne
et que nous soyons encore collectivement
dans l'amélioration de notre capacité à
l'indépendance énergétique donc il faut
mettre tout ça dans le même pot et
inclure des cibles qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas prioritaires et on comprend
qu'elles ne le soit pas comme par
exemple la cible du propriétaire
aujourd'hui propriétaire occupant bon il
a les moyens il a pas les moyens que ça
lui coûte plus cher de payer son énergie
mais c'est son problème entre guillemets
mais son problème soit il le prend à
bras le corps et il rentre dans les
dispositifs et proactif avec toutes les
aides qu'on peut lui apporter pour que
son logement s'améliore que ça soit plus
confortable pour lui et moins coûteux
soit il ne le fait pas parce que il en a
pas les moyens
quand on dit en France c'est la parole
de certains acteurs de la vie publique
quand on est propriétaire on est riche
on fait l'erreur la plus monumentale
qu'on puisse faire le nombre de
propriétaires qui ne sont pas des gens
riches et qui sont même des gens parfois
en difficulté surtout en arrivant vers
l'âge de la retraite c'est considérable
on en connaît tous dans nos communes
bien évidemment donc
le propriétaire occupant qui n'est pas
détecté aujourd'hui comme une cible
nécessaire de la lutte contre toutes les
déperditions peu d'énergie et contre
tous les mal vivre dans son logement
c'est un sujet je ne sais pas comment
vous permettre de l'aborder mais en tous
les cas nous élu locaux nous-mère c'est
souvent le premier point d'entrée on a
des habitants qui viennent se plaindre
de leur propriétaire qui ne veut pas
leur permettre de vivre dans des
conditions décentes et on a quelques
moyens d'intervenir aujourd'hui et
j'espère qu'on en aura plus de main mais
on est pratiquement jamais interpellé
par un propriétaire occupant parce qu'il
pense peut-être que c'est pas la
puissance publique de s'en occuper
parce qu'il est peut-être un petit peu
gêné de reconnaître qu'il est
propriétaire de son propre logement mais
que son propre logement devient un
logement qui n'est pas un logement
confortable et qui n'est pas peut-être
un logement décent ou sens où on
l'entendrait si on était propriétaire
avec l'exigence du locataire que le
logement soit bien sûr descend donc je
voulais vraiment dire cela parce que ça
me semble important de le faire je
terminerai sur l'exemplarité des
collectivités
qui a été rappelé que vous avez reprises
et qui est un sujet extrêmement complexe
on ne peut
parler aux gens de manière crédible que
si on est soi-même relativement crédible
et exemplaire bon et en fait là vous
abordez le sujet du logement mais il y a
le sujet de tout ce qui fait la
caractéristique des collectivités
locales surtout celles du blog communal
c'est à dire les équipements publics
leur état leur maintient en état leur
rénovation et le coût qu'il représente
pour le budget de la collectivité auquel
contribue une partie des habitants de la
commune au travers de la taxe foncière
c'est vrai que si demain je reviens à
mon propos liminaire si demain
l'évolution des choses fait qu'on se
rapproche dans la décision et dans la
mise en oeuvre et l'accompagnement de la
mise en oeuvre des décisions vers les
collectivités locales ce que nous ne
refuserons jamais dans le principe mais
pour lequel nous exigerons les moyen de
le faire il faudra impérativement que en
parallèle avec les mêmes questions que
celle que j'ai posé au début la capacité
de la vie économique et du monde
économique à nous accompagner nous nous
soyons trouver en situation de prolonger
l'effort et de le mener à terme mais je
crains que ça soit le tonneau de
Danaïdes qui consiste à rénover nos
propres bâtiments à je peux affirmer
aujourd'hui que bien sûr tout est inégal
sur l'ensemble du territoire mais les
communes françaises n'ont pas attendu
toutes les crises que nous traversons
qui font accélérer nos réflexions sur
ces sujets pour se lancer non seulement
dans le maintien en bon état de nos
équipements mais dans l'anticipation sur
les besoins
énergétiques de ces bâtiments ne
serait-ce que parce que ça coûte cher et
on la vérifie en 2022 ou l'envoler des
prix de l'énergie a fait se confronter
les collectivités locales avec des
dépenses considérables que nous n'avions
pas inscrites bien évidemment à nos
budgets primitifs 2022 pourtant pas lu
bien assumer donc sur sur cet exemple
j'insiste sur le fait qu'il faut
effectivement la prôner mais que elle
elle double l'enjeu de la capacité
globale de l'économie et de tous les
financements à auxquels nous devons
faire appel à
de l'atteindre pour pouvoir
effectivement être prescripteur
accompagnateur éventuellement
sanctionneur
avec l'image qui puisse être installée
dans l'opinion publique que si nous
faisons c'est que nous avons la capacité
de le faire et que nous n'utilisons pas
un pouvoir alors que nous-mêmes n'avons
pas balayé devant notre propre porte
alors sur les différentes questions qui
ont été posées et en complément puisque
je partage pas mal de points qui ont été
avancés
sur la question de la compétence des
collectivités
on l'a dit pour moi
il y a une nécessité absolue d'être en
contact avec la population au plus
proche donc c'est vrai que le bloc
communal est quand même bien armé pour
faire ce genre de choses dans la limite
des moyens dont ils disposent mais on a
au moins la proximité et ça a été
souligné tout à l'heure le contact
direct à l'habitant et je viens du coup
sur le guichet unique devrait non pas
être limité à un guichet unique
d'accueil et d'orientation mais à une
force de frappe finalement qui puisse
aller vers le citoyen j'ai testé ça sur
mon territoire avec la poste en
l'occurrence ça aurait pu être un autre
mais avec la poste c'est à dire que les
facteurs sont allés frapper un certain
nombre de portes en disant voilà est-ce
que vous êtes intéressé caméra et ça
passe si mal fonctionné que ça c'est à
dire que on a amené un certain nombre de
gens à se poser ou à la question et donc
à enclencher quelque chose avec toutes
les limites qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
sur
la différence entre le premier le
premier contact et la réalisation finale
donc
en ce qui concerne ce guichet unique
c'est vrai que si on a déguché unique
par étape ça
simplifie pas les choses clairement donc
il faut un guichet unique qui soit plus
proactif et comme je l'indiquais juste
avant et en même temps qui traite au
moins une partie significative de
l'opération
deuxième deuxième élément la différence
sur les territoires
elle est évidente
en fait pour la caractériser et pour que
les territoires plus justifiés
finalement des façons de pratiquer
différentes je pense que ce qu'on a
besoin c'est d'élaborer des stratégies
territoriales en la matière je vais
prendre un exemple
simple
mon territoire a un réseau de chaleur
important c'est 55000 équivalents
logements donc ça c'est déjà quelque
chose de significatif mais malgré tout
il y a une part des logements il y en a
à peu près 130 000 donc logement habitat
pour le coup c'est pas directement
comparable puisque j'ai parlé
d'équivalents logements juste avant mais
pour situer un peu les choses donc j'en
ai un grand nombre qui sont hors de
portée entre guillemets immédiate du
réseau de chaleur ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que c'est peut-être pour cela
pour pour des raisons
financières notamment de niveau de
charge c'est peut-être sur les logements
qui sont en dehors du périmètre qu'il
faut insister pour aller vers de la
rénovation c'est qu'on peut pas tout
faire donc il y a bien des questions de
stratégie en fait territoriale
différencié et pour ça il faut que
l'exercice soit réalisé donc peut-être
que il y a une nécessité de poser comme
nécessité cette stratégie territoriale
à mes yeux il y a bien effectivement un
risque des engagements des collectivités
par rapport
aux accompagnateurs rénov c'est à dire
que si le système est trop compliqué
difficile d'accès et de compréhension
pour les collectivités elles-mêmes c'est
sûr que on va dire l'État veut s'en
débrouiller qui sont des bruits quoi
c'est pas tellement qu'une question de
financement c'est aussi une question de
posture parce que si on sait pas quel
rôle on doit jouer dans ce contexte
c'est sûr qu'on jouera pas drôle
et
sur
les batteries rénov enfin tout ce qu'on
a dit autour de ça il y a également un
autre élément qu'il faut prendre en
compte qui d'ailleurs est en si j'ai
bien compris il y en a de moins en moins
c'est le prêt à taux zéro
c'est un élément de complexité
supplémentaire
on l'a pas abordé mais il allait de soi
et
ça fait rentrer en jeu un autre acteur
fondamental c'est quand même le
financement privé bancaire
et là on a quand même un problème majeur
donc il y a bien un problème de
compétences de capacité à faire mais il
y a aussi un problème de financement
privé derrière tout ça c'est pas que du
financement public
et puis sur la question de la formation
des filières enfin les matériaux locaux
etc
à l'expérience le constat que je fais
c'est que
sacrément compliqué pour une
collectivité de censés dans ce genre de
choses on peut inciter on peut financer
on peut faire un certain nombre
d'opérations un peu exemplaires avec en
partenariat avec les entreprises moi je
pense qu'il y a une piste qui est celle
de la standardisation c'est-à-dire que
on sorte à quoi aujourd'hui on se heurte
au fait que pour monter des formations
pour monter des filières locales de en
matière de fourniture de matériaux
il faut pouvoir standardiser c'est à
dire si on fait du à chaque fois un
projet unique d'abord on perd beaucoup
de temps beaucoup d'argent dans les
phases initiales mais en plus on est
quand même sur un sur un patrimoine
immobilier en tous les cas dans
l'habitat mais dans le tertiaire privé
aussi
quand je vois facilement l'expression
toutes les boîtes à chaussures
commerciales qu'on a un peu partout donc
il y a bien la capacité de faire les
choses ce qui nous manque pour
standardiser c'est que par exemple si
j'ai un zone pavillonnaire des années 70
ou les
bâtiments sont enfin les maisons sont
presque identiques en tous les cas dans
leur principe de construction
c'est d'avoir une logique de groupe et
du coup à se tirer attirer des
entreprises en disant c'est 50 100 200
pavillons qu'on va rénover et donc là on
a vraiment un trou dans la raquette on a
rien pour faire ce genre de choses et
moi je autant je ne crois pas que les
collectivités en tous les cas du bloc
communal et la compétence d'ailleurs
dans les deux sens du terme pour aller
vers de la formation
aux filières autant avoir la capacité de
monter des opérations de groupe ça ça
pourrait être effectivement un effet un
levier signif icatif
et puis
sur
le comment la différenciation
urbain rurale puisque vous posez la
question enfin différents je veux dire à
la limite on a on a l'habitude c'est à
dire que sur la métropole de Dijon j'ai
la commune centre fait 160 000 habitants
la plus petite 145 habitants donc
forcément à un moment on se pose la
question voilà
oui merci donc cette cette question elle
est complexe mais ce qu'il y a de
l'espoir parce que l'intéresse beaucoup
les élus c'est une question qui est
intéressée élue qui intéresse les
citoyens et
de ce fait là comme beaucoup de
questions en lien avec la transition
écologique il faut se mettre autour de
cette table locale pour co-construire
cette solution on va avoir besoin et
donc alors vous allez dire je représente
intercommunalité de France alors ça va
être facile pour moi l'intercommunalité
est un lieu vraiment important pour
pouvoir réaliser cette cette
cette co-construction de solutions
autour de la rénovation énergétique et
de la transition énergétique pour
pouvoir faire comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure mettre en place une politique de
long terme mais qui soit bien adaptée et
qui puisse être aussi évalués parce que
si on demande à ces je partage tout à
fait c'est ces points d'information
c'est ces personnes c'est plateformes je
les appelle des plateformes ces
plateformes il va falloir qu'elle
traduisent aussi auprès des citoyens ce
qui comment comment on parle d'énergie
parce que et même auprès des élus c'est
quand même des fois c'est un jargon
c'est quand même compliqué si on veut
pouvoir proposer faire monter en
compétences les réflexions et les
approches globales de de
rénovation si on veut suivre et évaluer
voilà il va falloir quand même que cette
question là
les élus puissent la prendre à bras le
corps faut pas que ça soit quelque chose
qui soit extérieur moi je le vois au
niveau par exemple des énergies ren des
fois il y a la solution facile bon bah
il y a un prestataire qui arrive va
produire l'énergie renouvelable c'est
bon moi voilà mon défaut territoire il
fait de l'énergie renouvelable youpi
mais en fait on n'a pas c'est pas la
vraie question en fait même si on veut
mesurer les retombées locales il faut
que ce sujet là soit vraiment réfléchi
collectivement entre élus de plusieurs
communes et puis qu'on puisse échanger
débattre sur cette question il y a pas
enfin comme dans toutes les solutions
qu'on va trouver avec toutes ces
questions de résilience territoriale de
transition écologique moi je dis
toujours déjà on a des questions
complexes sur lesquelles il va falloir
trouver des réponses mais en plus on n'a
pas toutes les questions et il faut
avoir cette unité cet outil de
gouvernance en fait de la rénovation ou
de l'énergie locale je sais pas comment
on peut dire
dans laquelle on puisse discuter des
sujets parce que on est forcément en
amélioration continue aussi sur ces
sujets là je veux dire aujourd'hui on
voit bien des termes comme les éoliennes
c'est compliqué peut-être que demain
quand on les voit autrement on peut
peut-être avancer donc ça pour moi il y
a la même chose enfin il me semble que
et donc les chaînes intercommunales me
semble être la bonne échelle pour
co-construire cette solution donc c'est
un sujet qui intéresse et qui va
nécessiter pour à mon avis de choses
parce que là autour de la table on est
quand même tous des élus où on s'est
formé on s'est autoformé enfin on a fait
ce qu'on pouvait on a été aussi militant
peut-être dans certaines associations
enfin bref nous parcours nous ont engagé
sur ces voies de la transition
écologique énergétique mais on a un
besoin de formation des élus
parce que des élus on arrive quand on
arrive je n'ai lu on arrive avec nos
bagages bon alors on n'a pas forcément
des bagages de connaissances très
pointues c'est un sujet technique il
faut vraiment se plonger ce sujet là
pour avoir la connaissance et la
conscience des solutions qu'on va
proposer donc ça pose cette question là
et peut-être que dans ces groupes
ces collectif à l'échelle intercommunale
qui pourrait se mettre en place ben on
pourrait avoir aussi de la formation
locale parce que des fois c'est
difficile de faire partir les élus
toujours loin bon alors wilaya la visio
maintenant elle est webinaires c'est
bien mais on a besoin aussi de se voir
de le faire ensemble de réfléchir
ensemble et puis de d'affronter des fois
des des points de vue enfin et pour
trouver un consensus et on a besoin
aussi d'avoir donc comme je l'ai redis
je le redis une deuxième fois pour que
ces agents de plateformes qui auraient
donc la possibilité de d'accompagner de
suivre et d'évaluer les les éléments
faut aussi qu'ils soient formés à ce
fonctionnement de d'une d'un collectif
d'élus et à l'accompagnement alors je
sais pas si c'est peut-être le bouton à
5 pattes que je cherche que je recherche
enfin faudrait trouver avoir peut-être
des des fiches de poste en fait un peu
dédiées à ces questions là
pour pouvoir faire cet articulation
parce que cette articulation entre
justement pour pas que ces plateformes
elles restent quelque chose juste un
service qu'on donne qui est extérieur au
territoire avec des sous qui arrivent de
l'extérieur même si c'est l'état c'est
pas tout à fait qui arrive et finalement
bon bah voilà les gens se serrent
et c'est ça va pas être efficace il faut
qu'on
l'a pas elle peut cette efficacité et
qu'on puisse l'évaluer concrètement avec
cet outil il me semble que ça pourrait
être intéressant sachant que les
intercommunalités ils ont quand même
deux compétences qui vont bien en lien
avec ces questions là c'est la
compétence aménagement et la compétence
développement économique donc on peut
aussi faire de la transversalité sur ces
questions là sans bien sûr coûter le
plan climat qui je vous l'accorde n'a
pas toujours tous l'efficacité qu'on
voudrait qu'il est mais ça permettrait
de de ressortir peut-être de cartons
certains certaines réflexions qui
auraient été faites et puis on a besoin
de du long terme c'est à dire qu'on doit
les élus ils sont que de passage les
techniciens et normalement ils sont un
peu plus longtemps là donc il faut aussi
que ça puisse se transmettre d'un élu à
l'autre parce que ça c'est des sujets
qui sont peu clivant en principe voilà
donc c'était le complément que je
voulais apporter par rapport à ce que
mes collègues nous présentaient si
Monsieur délégué général d'amorce et
ensuite à nos collègues qui poseront
quelques dernières questions je vais
faire court sur le guichet unique je
vais je vais paraphraser qui Geoffroy
mais effectivement pour pourquoi est-ce
que est-ce qu'on sous-entend un
opérateur unique ou plein d'opérateurs
et les mêmes que d'habitude au même
endroit derrière une table c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose donc si c'est
un guichet unique dans lequel derrière
il y a Lana la collectivité France
rénove la compagnateur et non je suis
pas sûr que seront tiennent là une
révolution finalement parce que le sujet
le sujet n'est peut-être pas là
par contre sur la question vous évoquez
la question de je voudrais quand même
revenir sur la la question de France
rénov c'est je manquerai à mes devoirs
si je vous je disais pas que c'est quand
même fou que ce dispositif soit aussi
précaire économiquement puisque en fait
là on vient d'apprendre qu'on avait un
an de plus d'accord on est en train de
parler d'un dispositif qui peut
s'arrêter chaque année presque tous les
trois ans selon les les périodes de C2
et enfin ça publique sont que si je me
rappelle bien la première des choses
assez publique c'est la continuité c'est
ça donc
un service public qui se renouvelle en
financement tous les ans tous les trois
ans c'est pas très sérieux y compris par
rapport je crois que c'est vous qui le
disiez à la question de la pérennité des
emplois trouver aujourd'hui un opéra un
opérateur de France rénov en lui disant
bah on est là pour un an deux ans
peut-être c'est pas une manière de
donner une sorte de de carrière
professionnelle assez personne là sur la
question de mon accompagnateur rénov et
je crois Guillaume Gontard évoqué le
risque de superposition comment les
collectivités se positionner c'est vrai
qu'on a un certain nombre de
collectivité enfin le mois
accompagnement finalement revêt des
réalités très différentes on n'a pas
parlé des slimes et peut-être que mes
collègues du clair en parleraient mais
le premier niveau d'accompagnement c'est
de la formation
les accompagnement le deuxième c'est un
accompagnement qui ressemble davantage
en particulier chez précaire à une forme
de pré-diagnostic pré diagnostic n'est
pas un accompagnement jusqu'au moment où
les travaux se finissent ensuite il y a
des accompagnements un peu plus
sophistiqués qui vont jusqu'à l'étude de
faisabilité mais qui s'arrête à l'étude
de faisabilité technique et puis il y a
ceux qui accompagnent y compris
l'ingénierie financière qui vont
chercher les aides à gaucher à droite et
puis l'accompagnement peut même aller ça
a été testé par certains et ça nous
amené sur un mot qu'on a pu utiliser
mais tirefinancement mais des
collectivités je pense en particulier à
Île-de-France énergie qui a tenté
d'aller au bout du raisonnement d'être
un opérateur de la rénovation jusqu'à
financer auto-financier ou préfinancé
les travaux à assurer la réalisation
donc le mois accompagnement il est il
est très flou il me semble de mon point
de vue comme on l'accompagnateur Renov
tel qu'il a été prévu n'est pas un
accompagnateur jusqu'à de tout le
processus que je viens de décrire en
gros c'est des c'est des maîtres d'eau
des maîtres d'oeuvre voir éventuellement
maître d'ouvrage mais ça a pas plus loin
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on clarifie
la notion d'accompagnement et nous on
parle nous on d'ailleurs entre nous
l'accompagnement
[Musique]
financement on va pas se le cacher si on
avance pas aussi vite c'est d'abord un
problème de sous de coercition et de
soumets dessous et là comme il y a
quelques chiffres que je mets sur la
table après c'est juste pour faire des
barres mais
en gros l'estimation aujourd'hui de
l'effort d'investissement à faire sur la
rénovation énergétique estime à 31
milliards d'euros sur d'ici 2030 c'est
énorme je rappelle juste que le parc
nucléaire à prévoir c'est 51 milliards
d'euros on est dans le même ordre de
grandeur il faudra se poser la question
de l'effort global de du pays entre des
outils de production d'ailleurs pour
mettre tout le monde d'accord le
développement de l'éolien si on veut
qu'il soit à la hauteur je crois que
c'est 19 milliards donc on est dans des
heures de grandeur et on a l'impression
que il semble plus aisé d'arbitrer un 51
ou un 19 de prod de production d'énergie
que un 31 de d'économie d'énergie et
donc il faudra probablement mettre tous
ces chiffres sur la table une finesse
c'est toujours un Français qui paye donc
je pense que c'est intéressant de de
peser ces grandes masses financières qui
méritent d'ailleurs peut-être d'être
affiné consolider mais c'est juste pour
se rendre compte que on attend ça dire
non mais la rénovation ça peut pas c'est
c'est tellement d'argent en jeu on est
sur le point de mettre en place des
parcs de production du notaire à peu
près similaire vous m'imposer des
questions sur les réseaux de chaleur
donc sur la question du raccordement
effectivement on a fait passer une
mesure grâce
je crois que c'est ça c'est fait non
c'est pas c'est pas un projet de loi
c'est un acte réglementaire mais
une aide au raccordement qui a été
largement améliorée sur le logement
collectif donc aujourd'hui on dit c'est
un peu simpliste mais qu'en gros
raccordement coûte 200 euros par
logement ça vaut plutôt pour des petits
immeubles grâce à un coup de pouce à une
opération coup de pouce C2 sur le
raccordement des réseaux de chaleur par
contre ça fonctionne mal avec le
logement individuel et on commence à
avoir des demandes de logement
individuel en particulier dans le monde
rural puisqu'on a des réseaux de chaleur
de petite taille tout à l'heure j'ai dit
qu'il fallait des réseaux de charge j'ai
parlé entre 10000 et 30 000 habitants
mais il y a aussi plein de réseaux de
chaleur sur des collectivités de 500 700
800 habitants donc on peut le faire
école mairie et puis quelques maisons
mais on n'est pas encore très à l'aise
sur la question de la du raccordement
individuel on travaille avec les
bailleurs sociaux on a monté un comité
des usagers des abonnés des réseaux de
chaleur et leur attente sont très
intéressantes vraiment on a eu une
discussion technique en particulier sur
les informations qu'ils ont besoin x
énergétique et ce qu'on est en train de
préparer avec plusieurs plusieurs
structures c'est un des outils de
simulation cartographique de en gros
une sorte de SIG à la fois des réseaux
existants qui permet à une copropriété à
bailleur de voir quel est le réseau le
plus proche et s'il peut se raccorder et
à quel prix et donc nous amorcer est
chargé du simulateur pris environnement
donc ça ça donnerait quelle facture à la
copro et ça ça éviterait combien de CO2
pour faire simple et également ça
permettrait de simuler des réseaux de
chaleur là où il y en a pas donc là
c'est un double outil un outil plutôt
pour les usagers pour dire est-ce que je
peux me raccorder un réseau de chaleur
existant et un outil qui serait plutôt
pour les élus en disant ah c'est vrai
que si je raccorde mon école ma mairie
et puis mes bailleurs sociaux etc mais
je peux faire un réseau et donc ça
serait un
on le fait avec les tailles une startup
d'État qui travaille avec nous sur le
sujet et puis le serema et puis la
région sud voilà on a un
d'accord mais je voulais citer la région
sud totalement au hasard bien entendu
donc on a vraiment un dynamique très
intéressante pour que le réseau de
chaleur devienne plus l'exception mais
la règle c'est un peu ça la ne plus
avoir de réseau de chaleur aujourd'hui
c'est pas très normal voilà
insister sur le fait que sur les réseaux
de chaleur et de manière générale sur la
chaleur renouvelable on est on est un
collectif le club de la chaleur
renouvelable qui réunit le Syndicat des
énergies renouvelables à feden et nerf
plan le club yoga enfin toutes les
énergies renouvelables la FPG pour la
géothermie a proposé la semaine dernière
à Madame panier renacher un plan
Marshall de la chaleur renouvelable en
disant qu'on est probablement capable
d'atteindre au moins 50 voire 75% de
chaleur issues de ces chaleurs
renouvelables locales fatale et la
découverte qu'on a fait qui va peut-être
vous surprendre c'est que depuis 20 ans
plus quasiment plus un logement ne
prévoit une boucle d'eau chaude et si
vous n'avez pas un tuyau qui permet de
distribuer de l'eau chaude vous ne
pouvez pas raccorder on s'en est rendu
compte pendant la crise parce qu'on a eu
énormément de demandes de raccordement
au moment où le gaz électricité a
explosé et on s'est rendu compte que
dans une rue il y avait 9 logements
collectifs immeubles collectif sur 10
qui n'avait pas de boucle d'eau chaude
et si vous n'avez pas de boucle d'eau
chaude et pas de possibilité de mettre
un emplacement pour une un échangeur
vous ne pouvez pas raccorder on a refusé
un nombre de raccordement inimaginable
pendant la séquence donc il faut
absolument que la future réglementation
environnementale prévoit l'emplacement
de ces boucles d'eau chaude pour faire
pouvoir circuler de l'eau chaude au
passage à la fois pour accorder un
réseau de chaleur mais aussi pour faire
des chaufferies bois de base de Badi
meubles y compris pour faire des pompes
à chaleur de bonne qualité de Bad
immeuble il faut qu'on puisse distribuer
de l'eau chaude dans dans les logements
pour chauffer alors aujourd'hui la
plupart des logements finalement sont
piégés entre du chauffage électrique et
une chaudière à gaz et et pour longtemps
et se dire que un immeuble qui est
construit aujourd'hui ne pourra être
chauffé que par du chauffage électrique
soit convecteur soit pompe à chaleur
soit par du gaz c'est quand même très
problématique sur les 30 ou 40
prochaines années et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on travaille actuellement à une aide
spécifique de l'État à la création de
ces boucles d'eau chaude dans les
logements dans les immeubles existants
mais ça va coûter cher vous imaginez il
faut trouver les dalles etc donc il faut
vite qu'on répare cette cette erreur de
l'histoire que de ne pas avoir prévu ces
boucles d'eau chaude dans le logement
collectif
Laurent burgois souhaitait vous poser
une question oui merci Madame la prison
alors rapidement de questions plutôt
accès vous comprenez dans cette maison
sur les collectivités territoriales je
crois que vous l'avez un peu évoqué
monsieur Geoffroy dans le préliminaire
je crois que on va dire humoristique une
fois que notre pays sera apaisé le
pouvoir exécutif et législatif d'avoir
réfléchir à une nouvelle loi de
décentralisation
qui sera pas une nouvelle loi 3DS même
si le Sénat a apporté
je passe notamment à tous le volet
logement tu as notre collègue Dominique
Estrosi qui a apporté quand même
beaucoup de points positifs dans ce
domaine là mais je crois qu'il va
falloir réfléchir qui fait quoi que fait
l'état que fait les collectivités dans
ma première question c'était plutôt pour
vous Madame Hébert par rapport à la
regarder est-ce que intercommunalité de
France serait pris à discuter
avec des modalités précises un transfert
de compétence communalité ont déjà toute
la compétence on va dire habitat avoir
tous les financements de la rénovation
énergétique gérer par les
intercommunalités mais en état vous avez
déjà les aides à la pierre pour les
aider est-ce que vous souhaitez avoir
tous les dispositifs quels qu'ils soient
en matière d'habitat en étant bien sûr
et je me mets à votre place partir un
vigilant sur ce transfert de compétences
et d'évolution et d'évolution bien sûr
des moyens financiers et puis par
rapport aux autres personnes là
actuellement l'État est plutôt par
rapport dans toujours au collectivités
territoriales l'État a mis en place à
plus de la desciles le fond vert que
pensez-vous de ce fond vert messieurs
est-ce que quels sont les premiers
retours est-ce que pour vous notamment
je passe moi qui suis du gars j'ai
beaucoup de retours de petites communes
qui me disent que
ils ne peuvent pas demander un fromage
parce qu'ils n'ont pas l'ingénierie
interne et qu’une fois de plus ils vont
échapper à ces êtres de l'État voilà
rapidement les deux questions que je
souhaitaient vous poser
alors
merci
donc bien sûr intercommunalité de France
est toujours prête à réfléchir à ce ces
questions là après je ne veux pas je ne
peux pas engager les positions mais si
ça peut servir l'efficacité
de la rénovation énergétique bien
entendu on est prêt à discuter voilà
après c'est à voir aussi dans le couple
commune intercommunalité je veux dire
faut pas comment on pourrait travailler
ensemble sur cette question et bien
entendu on est tout à fait c'est
toujours l'esprit de intercommunalité de
France c'est de réfléchir et de
co-construire ensemble ce genre de
réponse
oui bon les panneaux qui sont devant
nous sont trop petits pour que tout y
soit dit ce qui me permet de rappeler
que la MF et l'Association des maires de
France est président d'intercommunalités
ce qui ne fait pas différence
fondamentale avec nos amis
d'intercommunalité de France si je dis
ça c'est parce que en fait surtout ces
sujets la question n'est pas de figer
les choses à un niveau stratifié notre
fameux millefeuille tant dénoncer
mais de définir la pertinence du niveau
d'intervention
laquelle pertinence n'est pas
obligatoirement toujours celle d'une
commune ou celle d'une intercommunalité
ça dépend vraiment du tissu humain et
territorial dans lequel nous sommes et
je pense que
il vaut mieux parler du bloc communal
d'ailleurs l'intercommunalité je
rappelle que ce n'est pas la
supracommunalité que les
intercommunalités sont des
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale pas des collectivités
territoriales et que et que c'est donc à
l'échelle du bloc communal et de sa
capacité à intégrer prendre en charge de
manière pertinente dans la subsidiarité
vraiment au sens le plus profond du
terme qu'il faut envisager la question
je confirme bien sûr à ce qui a été dit
par ma collègue le bloc communal est
désireux non pas d'assumer tout mais de
faire ce qu'il est le mieux placé pour
faire tout simplement et avec les moyens
qui lui permettent de le faire tout
simplement alors sur la question fond
vert
il faut jamais trop sévère et jamais
trop sévère rapidement comme il faut
jamais être trop enthousiasme
enthousiasme non plus rapidement lorsque
pour la première fois qu'il a eu à
évoqué le sujet peu après sa prise de
fonction le ministre Christophe Béchu a
présenté à la représentation de l'AMF
dont je faisais partie le dispositif
fond vert on pouvait effectivement
croire à une vraie révolution de type
copernicien à on était plus sur du
vertical avec appel à projet on était
sur le local qui décide déterminer
obtient on était sur un volume
considérable
on le constatera le jour venu mais j'ai
tendance à penser qu'il se réduit de
plus en plus mais ce qui est ajouté aux
aides de l'État par rapport à ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui et toujours bon à prendre et
on ne va certainement pas à critiquer un
dispositif qui n'a pas fait encore la
démonstration de sa qualité ou de son
absence de qualité par une véritable
évaluation par contre les retours que
vous avez moi je les ai dans mon propre
département malgré la volonté des
représentants de l'État nous avons
obtenu de du gouvernement qu'il donne
des consignes aux représentants de
l'État pour être le plus souple possible
dans le dialogue avec les associations
des locaux dans la stratégie de mise en
place du fond vert en relation et en
lien avec la DETR et la décile
mon préfet pour prendre l'exemple que je
connais bien avait même envisagé une
stratégie parfaitement intelligente qui
consistait à dire
tout ce qui venant des collectivités
peut rentrer dans le fond vert on le
passe d'abord dans le fond vert ce qui
permettra de dégager plus de créditr et
des cils pour des projets qui
manifestement ne pourraient pas émarger
au titre du fond vert or le calendrier
est venu nous démontrer que ça n'était
pas possible donc vous voyez bien fond
vert bon on va pas cracher dessus il
existe on espère qu'il ira au-delà de
2024 puisqu'on a cru comprendre qu'il
serait pérennisé en 2024 et une
politique publique de cette ampleur elle
doit avoir une certaine durée on espère
qu'il ne va pas se réduire comme peau de
chagrin et devenir même involontairement
une nouvelle machine à fabriquer de
l'appel à projet parce que on a bien vu
que
tous les documents à remplir toutes les
catégories ça commençait à redevenir de
l'appel à projet qu'il y avait encore
des cases à cocher si on les cochait pas
bah on passe à côté donc on aura je
pense et toutes les collectivités le
feront au contact du gouvernement et au
contact du Parlement on aura à évaluer
le plus rapidement possible la première
année fond vert pour proposer au
gouvernement avec je l'espère la pub du
Parlement à les évolutions qui me
semblent indispensables mais le fond
vert pourra probablement permettre aux
collectivités d'atteindre un certain
nombre d'objectifs qui vont dans le sens
de l'amélioration de la situation
climatique globale à laquelle nous
sommes appelés à contribuer
il faut comme toujours être vigilant le
plus objectif possible à
le plus confiant possible c'est vrai que
la vigilance est vraiment plus à
l'actualité aujourd'hui que la confiance
mais bon ça ça se travaille
peut-être deux mots pour faire vite
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de choses qui
ont été dit
sur la décentralisation j'y reviendrai
pas les éléments ont été donnés sur le
fond vert et notamment
moi ce que ce que j'y vois elle est
remontée qu'on a sont plutôt de ce type
là il y a beaucoup de recyclage l'ordre
recyclage de choses existantes mais
aussi beaucoup de recyclage puisque
c'est ce qu'on demande on nous demande
d'aller vite sur les territoires donc
souvent on a des projets sont on n'a pas
de projet et c'est vrai que le problème
de l'ingénierie du coup se pose pour
ceux qui sont petits ou gros mais qui
n'avaient pas de projets qui pourraient
rentrer à peu près dans les dans les
cases qui vont bien
ça fait le résultat c'est que ça fait
beaucoup de saupoudrage
et en plus vous le savez on a évoqué de
multiples reprises on a des problèmes
aussi de délais c'est-à-dire de
pérennité non seulement financière mais
de pérennité du financement sur un
projet qui verra peut-être son
aboutissement en 2025 ou 2026 on nous a
déjà passionnés
ou c'est bien on avait le financement
mais c'est trop tard une fois qu'on est
qu'on a l'aboutissement du projet donc
moi je pense que le fond vert c'est une
bonne chose c'est vrai que les remontées
voilà ça nous donne un appel d'air ça
met en mouvement donc mais avec des
limites certaines que je viens d'évoquer
et qui ont été rappelés également
je vais faire court
en même temps vous posez deux questions
quasiment fondamentales les compétences
et les moyens donc c'est difficile de
faire court sur la question des
transferts je pense qu'à ce stade le
sujet est surtout la question de la
modulation c'est à dire que l'aide à la
pierre par exemple là mais on ne fait
qu'appliquer les règles de Lada de même
d'ailleurs dans 3ds où vous avez
introduit oui c'est le Sénat qui est
introduit l'idée qu'une partie du fond
chaleur soit affectée aux régions et en
même temps les régions l'obligation
d'appliquer les règles de l'ADEME donc
auquel cas on devient un opérateur de
l'État mais on n'est pas dans une forme
de transfert de compétences et de moyens
sur le fond vert j'aurais complété les
propos de de Guy Geoffroy et de Jean
Patrick Masson également madame sur une
autre élément du fond vert qui nous
interpelle donc qui nous a appelé à la
retenue dans la critique
ce qui est surprenant c'est que
d'habitude quand on parle de de
financement de la transition écologique
on est très soucieux de la bonne
usage de l'argent
et là on a un fond qui est un peu un
open bar quand même c'est à dire que
vous venez vous dites combien vous
voulez et peut-être que et puis un jour
ça on dit il y a plus d'argent et ça
donne quelque chose et c'est Guillaume
évoqué le thème CV c'était quand même
l'un des reproches TCV avec des qualités
ça a déclenché beaucoup de choses très
vite mais l'inconvénient majeur c'est
que c'était un peu la foire d'empoigne
et puis enlever la main on avait de
l'argent on avait pas de l'argent on n'a
pas évalué l'efficacité enfin c'est rare
ce si faible niveau de de
rationalisation de des aides publiques
donc nous on appelle à ce qui est quand
même des grilles minimales au moins que
les opérateurs de l'État qui s'y
connaissent comme l'ADEME et je crois
que c'est un peu le cas quand même soit
quand même face instrument instruisent
les dossiers c'est assez surprenant
parce qu'à un moment donné ce qu'on
craint c'est cet été dit c'est qu'à mon
avis il y a plus d'argent c'est fini ça
s'arrête là il fallait voilà et il
fallait lever la main plutôt il fallait
lever la main plutôt donc ça c'est après
pour pour prendre un peu de hauteur nous
ce qu'on propose aujourd'hui on sort que
la transition écologique un peu à tourne
en terre beaucoup de choses ont été
faites mais mais mais mais mais mes
moyens à la fois juridique et financier
nous limite dans la rénovation
énergétique mais je pourrais vous parler
du tri du tri sélectif je pourrais vous
parler de sobriété haut enfin il y a
vraiment des sujets sur lesquels les
moyens financiers dont on va avoir
besoin sont beaucoup plus élevés que ce
qui sont proposés même quand ils sont
plus élevés et il nous semble qu'il
manque un objet aujourd'hui au sein du
Parlement c'est une loi de programmation
du financement de la transition
écologique quelque chose qui donnerait
qui d'ailleurs comment dire
réconcilier les Français avec la
fiscalité environnementale on a quand
même vécu un coup d'arrêt monumental
avec la taxe carbone comment on peut
réconcilier cette idée qu'il faut un
signal prix sur les usages les moins les
les comportements les moins vertueux et
en même temps qu'on a besoin d'argent
pour mobiliser les comportements les
plus vertueux ça s'appelle une loi et
l'idée c'est vous en avez la charge
c'est de d'apporter une forme de
prévisibilité au signal prix ce qu'on
n'a pas toujours fait on a monté la TGAP
on a baissé la taxe carbone enfin les
redevances de l'eau c'est un peu pareil
d'assurer l'équité c'est ce qui nous a
été beaucoup reproché pendant un gilet
jaune quand même une forme une équité en
particulier sur les plus captifs
d'assurer une affectation de la
fiscalité environnementale à son objet
je vous rappelle pour un autre sujet qui
nous est cher que 70% de la TGAP qui a
été faite pour éviter la mise en
décharge des déchets n'est pas affecté à
l'économie circulaire et à la dame ça
affecte obligé général donc il y a une
question d'affectation et aussi de
distribution entre l'échelon national et
les gestion des collectivités locales je
pense en particulier Jean-Patrick on a
parlé à la fiscalité carbone aujourd'hui
on nous a demandé de faire des Plans
Climat mais on nous a pas donné la part
de la fiscalité carbone on nous demande
aujourd'hui d'être plus présent sur
l'efficacité énergétique mais sans nous
en donner les moyens ou peu ces deux
œufs un an comme je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure voilà ça donnerait quand même
j'allais dire un projet environnemental
au pays qui est aussi un projet de
financement de de la transition
écologique c'est un objet qui manque
bon nombre de ministres qu'on a pu
auditionner enfin l'ont appelé de leur
vie on dit qu'il fallait aujourd'hui
pouvoir arriver à une loi de
programmation sur la transition
écologique et énergétique c'est une
réalité est-ce que parmi nos collègues
il y aurait d'autres questions non
monsieur Dagbert tout à tout a été dit
souscrit à bon nombre de ce que l'on a
entendu juste sur la réaffirmation peut
être de la proximité du rôle que les
élus locaux peuvent jouer auprès de la
population parce que c'est vers eux que
la population se tourne peut-être aussi
sur le rôle de l'interco compte tenu des
compétences majeures qu'elle exerce sur
un territoire assez vaste et dans le
respect puisque là ce sont les élus
locaux qui sont en même temps les
administrateurs de l'EPCI et donc compte
tenu des compétences en matière
de logement en matière de d'aménagement
du territoire et de développement
économique
peut-être aussi être en capacité d'être
ce point de rencontre pour bâtir une
politique non pas seulement énergétique
mais aussi une politique en matière de
chaleur et d'être en capacité avec
l'ingénierie parce que à chaque fois on
bute sur la question de l'ingénierie
bien souvent à l'échelle communale dans
un département je suis un département
très similaire ou votre puisque le
Pas-de-Calais est à la fois
urbain et rural et on nous compare
souvent le 62 et 77 et donc je pense que
en matière d'ingénierie c'est peut-être
aussi le bon niveau que
l'intercommunalité pour répondre à ça et
puis dernier point peut-être aussi être
en capacité de faire un diagnostic des
calories perdues et qui ne sont pas
récupérés je pense notamment sur un
territoire lorsque vous avez des
industries qui sont très consommatrices
d'énergie il y a parfois des calories
qui partent et qui deviennent donc
fatale pense notamment puisque je viens
d'un territoire où nous avons un gaz
fatal puisque de toute manière il
s'échappe et il vient augmenter alors
c'est bien qu'il faut limiter
et sortir l'énergie carbonée mais
puisque de toute manière il s'échappe et
donc on a même des puits qui permettent
ce qu'on appelle les évents en cas de
nappe et donc aujourd'hui on est en
capacité de le récupérer de le
réinjecter dans le réseau de gaz ce qui
donne notamment des réseaux de chaleur
et puis l'échelle de l'intercommunalité
me paraît aussi être la bonne échelle
pour expertiser et peut-être accompagné
les élus locaux dans la faisabilité d'un
réseau de chaleur vous évoquiez à juste
titre les petits réseaux de chaleur et
ça n'a rien de péjoratif mais ça force
de démonstration que c'est possible à
cette échelle là aussi et donc être en
capacité d'avoir
ce retour des bonnes pratiques et
d'accompagner les collectivités dans la
crédibilité de la Constitution ou pas
d'un réseau de chaleur
dernier point aussi India à l'esprit
parce que j'y tiens beaucoup j'ai eu
l'occasion de participer à un programme
d'échange européen sur ces questions là
et de me rendre notamment en Hollande où
ils ont réussi à faire un réseau de
chaleur sur la géothermie à partir des
eaux d'exorent des puits de mine et donc
ça aussi c'est ce qui vient à la force
de la démonstration qui a été à votre de
dire que il faut à la fois être en
capacité d'écrire un schéma et qui fait
quoi de simplifier qui est fait quoi
pour que ce soit lisible et là je vous
rejoins pleinement aussi parce que nos
concitoyens se moquent de savoir tout ça
il considère que c'est notre cuisine à
terme que c'est à nous
dans un espace comme solide ce matin à
nous mettre d'accord à trouver les
bonnes rédactions mais eux ce qu'ils
veulent c'est j'ai mon souci qui peut le
régler et c'est généralement vers vous
qui se tourne donc voilà les quelques
réflexions que vos échanges m'ont
inspiré en tout cas un grand merci à
chacun de vous
oui
rapidement
m'a fait penser à certains de choses sur
la question du déploiement des réseaux
de chaleur d'abord effectivement il y a
une ingénierie du réseau de chaleur qui
manque je donne quelques exemples et par
exemple l'agglomération de l'Orient
c'est à embaucher un chargé de mission
réseau de chaleur son objectif un réseau
de chaleur par commune de
l'intercommunalité et ils sont en train
de les faire ils sont en train de finir
donc bientôt l'agglomération de Lorient
aura un réseau de chaleur par commune de
l'intercommunalité Bordeaux va
multiplier par 8 dans une agglomération
plus grande ces réseaux de chaleur donc
on a besoin de cette ingénierie des gens
qui vont qui vont voir les élus en lui
disant apparaît est-ce que vous y avez
pensé et généralement ça provoque un nom
mais on va le faire et ça et ça ça
débouchera un projet d'ailleurs l'ADEM a
augmenté ses aides de faisabilité à 80%
sur les réseaux de chaleur donc on a
vraiment un dispositif intéressant vous
vous évoquez la chaleur fatale
effectivement à proximité il y a aussi
il y a aussi Dunkerque qui alimente une
grande partie de sa agglomération avec
la chaleur de la désacry et on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait un immense
potentiel qui était peu effectivement
développé d'ailleurs de la chaleur très
très haute température mais de la
chaleur moyenne température voire basse
température et donc ce qu'on propose
dans le fameux plan Marshall c'est un
plan national de d'évaluation des
potentiels de chaleur avec des
financements locaux mais on a énormément
de projets actuellement de récupération
de chaleur de chaleur fatale donc
beaucoup de choses à imaginer également
dans ce dans ce champ là je crois que
c'est tout ce que je voulais dire mais
vous avez raison pour information les
réseaux de chaleur il y en a à peu près
1000 en France il y en a 700 avec du
bois principalement en énergie de base
il y en a 150 avec la valorisation
énergétique de déchets il y en a 50 60
avec la géothermie profonde et puis on
voit se développer des réseaux de
chaleur avec la chair fatale quelques
dizaines de la chaleur solaire donc on
commence à avoir des réseaux de chaleur
solaire de la récupération data center
sur lequel au passage on vous a déjà
proposé des amendements mais il faut
absolument que quand on implanta data
center on l'oblige à avoir une solution
de récupération de la chaleur ça doit
être un élément du positionnement de
datacenter alors que là il se positionne
à proximité des ordinateurs pour faire
simple donc il y a vraiment un immense
potentiel biogaz qui concerne des
réseaux de chaleur au biogaz qui se
développe donc on a vraiment un panel
très très large et les réseaux de
chaleur leur histoire c'est ils se sont
toujours adaptés à la situation en
changeant d'énergie c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on croit que la mono énergie et le
tout électrique c'est dangereux
stratégiquement vaut mieux avoir
plusieurs énergies et puis en changer
quand ça se passe bien ça se passe
et bien côté merci beaucoup pour ces
échanges très intéressants qui ont duré
un certain temps mais qui étaient
passionnants et de nous avoir consacré
autant de temps merci et bonne journée à
vous